[Music]
all right
ladies and gentlemen hello and welcome
already got a tier one
membership coming in from machop172
machop thanks so much welcome
we got dylan here tonight we got logan
we got the sorting hat yo ladies and
gentlemen the sorting hat
here live
i'm gonna turn down my uh
i feel like my mic is still just a
little bit too loud when i go back and
listen to this recording
so let's see check check check one two
one two
how about right in here check check
check one two ladies and gentlemen might
check
maybe up one more decibel
right in there check check check yeah i
think i like that i think i like that
looks like we got ellie here again
reuben is here
i deep
yog
rebecca
looks like we got quite a few ravenclaws
in the house tonight 2 a.m stream
for waltz 79 a walls thank you for being
here
james prince let's go retro love your
work hey james appreciate your support
we got brandon here we got nicholas
we got amore poet once again i remember
seeing that name before
hi iq warrior what's up welcome back
yogg y awg welcome jay rossi what's up
recognize that name too david
jonathan hey that's my first name
welcome man we must have a lot of you
guys over uh in europe because
every time i say i'm going live around 8
p.m it's alway i get a lot of people
like oh really
like trust me i wish i could go live
much earlier i do
i do but i don't get home till about 6
p.m eastern time
so that's like that's enough time for
dinner you know get some time with the
kids then you gotta get the kids in bed
and then it's it's right now it's eight
o'clock
let's see who else we got we got the
white wolf back as well stephen rice
tm03
yeah you guys like this music
i was like we got to find something else
that goes a little bit more with the
harry potter theme so i went online
and this is just a
non-copyright celtic medieval
tavr music i was like oh dude this is
this is vibes right here man
this is vibes i'm loving this
live dance laugh music love reuben did i
say reuben welcome reuben
blade dragon heart sorry if i missed you
guys
sorry if i missed you guys
all right we got about uh let's see
about six minutes i'm gonna go grab a
beverage
so
grab some snacks guys settle in
do what you need to do if you need to
take a quick break
i'm gonna grab some uh i think i'm gonna
go with a coke it's probably a cherry
coke zero that's been my go-to lately
zachary what's up gryffindors in the
house
zachary morris no way
are you too young to remember saved by
the bell zachary morris are you too
young
oh man i'm giving my age away again kylo
ren what's up welcome
whoopi what do you think we'll see at
gamescom oh we're gonna be talking a lot
about gamescom tonight gotta be talking
a lot about gamescom
all right guys i'll be back
victor rookwood oh my gosh
nobody panic everybody
remain
calm okay just remain calm remain calm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys
kylo ren subscribe to the channel thank
you guys for the subs
oh there was one more right before that
too
and i missed it
it's supposed to pop up in the chat but
i don't know for some reason not popping
up there might need to
look into upgrading that
or not upgrading but changing my uh
setting
[Music]
let's go man already up to 39 likes
before we're even officially live
got 134 of you in here right now that's
awesome
and boy do we have a lot to talk about
tonight guys
we have a lot to talk about
hello from portugal wow that is awesome
we got washington state we got portugal
i know we got some others
i saw earlier
um i was there in australia somebody
said it's like
2 a.m or 2 p.m i don't even remember
i know right it's like news is really
happening fast when the uh
when the release date is actually like
the old news now right
germany maddie from germany
welcome maddie welcome greetings from
brazil argentina oh my goodness this is
awesome
tom dude you're not supposed to tell
people that come on tom
come on tom
keep that to yourself
keep that to yourself tom
welcome guys to retro rack and tour live
norway dude this is crazy
this is crazy
dylan what's up dylan rocking the uh
those emotes man i'm tr i tried to fix
them it looks like they are fixed now
dylan because i noticed whenever you
were posting them
the slytherin one in particular was like
it was cutting it off on top
so i went back in and uploaded just a
slightly smaller version
we got niko here as well nico okay nico
throwing up all four of them nice so now
i can see them all yeah it looks like
everything is uh
is perfect
[Music]
greetings from hogsmeade rookwood oh my
goodness guys we got rookwood in the
chat
santiago yo let's give santiago shout
out welcome santiago
mexico here
that's awesome
all right guys so
jay rossi had a request for the music
i'm gonna paste it in the chat here
i just found this today because i was
like you know what we gotta get some uh
you know we gotta get some music that
fits the fits the vibes
fits the harry potter you know medieval
fantasy atmosphere
all right let me fix the
webcam just real quick it's just a
little bit too
let's see
there we go
actually you know what i might turn this
oh man
that's like a little bit too bright but
then that's a little bit too dark wait i
might be able to do this right here
oh there we go
there we go right in there
all right
ontario canada let's go
antoine yes we just we just got started
oh i'd love to do hedwig's theme rebecca
i'd love to but unfortunately that would
uh
probably get the live stream taken down
in a matter of about five seconds
yeah youtube's uh auto detection
on the copyrighted music would would
kick in really quick
so the whole live stream would just go
down
that's kind of a difference in like
youtube live streams versus twitch
twitch you'd get by with it
live but then your your vod would likely
get hit and that section would be muted
or they might even issue a takedown
so youtube you got to be you got to be
extra careful with the with what you're
playing on the live so i hope this uh
this website that i shared i hope it's
correct i'm pretty sure it is
but uh it's it's no copyright music so i
think we should be good
all right guys well we got a lot to talk
about we got a lot to talk about so i'm
going to switch over to the commentary
view here
so that we can actually look look at
this and let's turn down the music just
slightly
i still i think i want to keep the music
going but just have it a little bit more
in the background there we go
so i know everybody's already talking
about gamescom and we're definitely
going to get to gamescom but first i
mean we got to talk about
got to talk about the major the major
news right and i already i put up a
video on it but now that we've had some
time to
sit with this for a few days i want to
just uh
where's your head at guys how's
everybody feeling about the date
february 10 2023
chandler wood community manager actually
put out a post today asking how's
everybody feeling now that we uh
we've had time to kind of think on it
over the weekend
i totally should have seen it coming
because
hey
i post the video early let's see we
found out on friday right yeah friday i
posted a video early friday morning and
the day before he had that's when he had
posted a thing about hey our usual
thursday thing's not happening
um we still got something planned for
this week but it's it's pushed to
tomorrow
i should have known right then man
because
pr 101 is like you you drop
kind of something that might be bad news
it's like you drop it on a friday
you dropping off this i mean people
don't follow this as much anymore
because the age of online
internet and marketing has has changed
that a bit but back in the day you know
when it was just like newspapers and tv
people would drop their bad news on a
friday friday afternoon 5 p.m
because you know then they kind of have
the weekend for things to hopefully
settle down so it's like i wonder if
that's what they were doing here
i did see your comment earlier zachary
too about that you you are old enough to
know who that is then you get asked
where's slater and screech oh man i bet
you hear that a lot
yo carlos with the super chat carlos
thank you so much
see what carlos question here is me and
my mom are the only harry potter fans
out there
uh family we are proud gryffindor's nice
uh
that's awesome so not even a question
just showing support to the stream
proud gryffindor here as well and aaron
thank you so much for subbing to the
channel
yeah proud gryffindor here i gave
my eight-year-old son like he's too
early to be sordid but he
he knows i'm real into harry potter and
so he asks lots of questions and we we
talk about my wife being a hufflepuff
and me being gryffindor he's like what
what is that so i'm like okay we'll give
you the test
i i thought he would be ravenclaw or
gryffindor he got slytherin
which is fine you know
not all slytherins are bad but he's only
eight so i'm like well we need to we
need to do it again when he's like 11.
see see what he gets then when he would
actually be going to hogwarts
[Music]
windowpanes have the mascots in the same
order as the hourglasses in the movies
jonathan totally okay with the delay
never experienced a cyberpunk game again
in my life
i mean i'll be honest with you guys i
making uh having a hogwarts legacy
centric youtube channel and tweeting
about it a lot
i i see and read a lot i was
actually pretty surprised i thought the
reaction was going to be worse
so i feel like the vast majority of
people
i would say
70 percent are good with it
there's probably another 20 percent i
don't know maybe a little bit
maybe about 60 percent who are like i'm
totally good then about 30 percent who
are like oh this stings
i'm not happy about it but
i'm okay with it you know if it results
in a better game jay rossi i think this
is right where you were i remember
reading your comment saying you were
disappointed
but you you know you come to understand
it right and then i would only say you
know 10 10 5 10 percent or so that i saw
like people really mad
some people saying they should just
cancel the game like what
what
um but yeah i i was uh i was pretty
surprised i feel like it went over
fairly well for the most part i think it
helped the fact they were able to give a
solid date it's not just
hey we're delaying
it's hey here's the date so we went from
holiday 2022 to february 10th
2023 which is a friday
uh and if you really think about it like
this like i don't think anybody
at this point we were kind of all
expecting that early to mid december
i think people it's sort of like uh
november if they were going to do
november they should have said something
by now
so we were kind of moving on from
november so if you were if you were
already in your mind saying december
it's just two months basically two
months two months from what we were all
thinking now yes
they miss out on the big holiday
shopping season
but it'll come back again you know
they'll they'll be able to sell a lot in
february sell a lot in march then you
can have a big summer and then by the
time holidays roll around you got those
discounts kicking in right
sawyer says if the game comes in a
finished state then it's all good with
me
david says i'm gutted as i so want to
play but if they need more time than so
be it i want this game see that's that's
a i think that's perfectly reasonable
response david and i was i was happy to
see that
a lot of the people who were
disappointed that was
that was most of what i saw for the
people who were disappointed it's like
oh
yes i'm annoyed i so wanted to play this
but i didn't see a lot of people getting
mad and angry at the devs uh taking it
out on avalanche taking it on wb you
know which i i think is good
shot of the windows is beautiful yeah we
need to talk about the we need to talk
about the windows here you guys
because there are some interesting
oh wait is it not gonna let me zoom in
okay wait let me do this
i have to open the image in a new tab
and then okay now we can zoom in
give you guys a better shot of this
right here it's kind of blurry but
yeah i love that
you got hufflepuff here
uh what most believe to be hufflepuff's
cup right here
which would eventually become a horcrux
of course
here we have gryffindor
and you can just make out like you can
make out the badger
right there see that
and then you've got the h
for hufflepuff here
then here we've got gryffindor i'm still
trying to make out
the exact like
where the lion is exactly i mean it's
it's up in here somewhere
looks like the mane here but yeah this
one i have a little bit more trouble
seeing exactly where the lion is and
then of course you got the sword
the sword of gryffindor right here
[Music]
and dude why am i having such a hard
time oh wait because we're
this is the reflection so we're seeing
the outside of it yeah because i was
like what this looks like a p but now
now i see like from the other side that
would be a g right there
then we got ravenclaw here
almost a little bit of purple i mean
just the way the stained glass kind of
reflects probably
so you've got the eagle here you've got
the r
uh and then what i think is pretty
clearly the diadem
which would also go on to become a
horcrux of voldemort and then we have
slytherin here and this one i think is
the one that people are most unsure
about
i mean i feel like just to go with the
theme of the others it's gotta be
slytherin's locket it's like
would be the top of my list it to me it
visually it looks more like the
resurrection stone
but that would just be kind of
i don't know from what we know the
resurrection stone was a peverell family
thing
that marvolo gaunt eventually had in his
possession but i don't believe it was a
slytherin thing the locket of course was
a slytherin thing so
oh dude i hadn't even noticed the star
yet right there
more um astrological patterns
calen glad to catch you live hey callum
glad glad you got a chance to catch a
live stream i know a lot of you guys are
tuning in at crazy hours across other
countries i'm here in the u.s so it's
about 8 23 my time right now
i think this is what would later be
called the gaunt ring we'll see that's
like if it's the gaunt ring
then it should be the stone it should be
the resurrection stone
and i i agree with you like visually i
think it looks like that but to me it
doesn't fit i think it's uh i think it's
most likely gonna be the locket and some
people were saying it looks like an egg
i saw professor lynette was saying it
looks like an egg which i i could see
that too maybe it's like uh a basilisk
egg or something
joseph just noticed it's a tree also
branches and leaves at the top oh wait
let's see oh yeah right there
yeah i mean the artwork that we've seen
so far for this game is just downright
stunning i mean
it is just stunning now this of course
is the window that we see the other side
of when we're on the interior of
hogwarts in the uh sorting ceremony
so
i'm telling you man people are going to
be spending hours
and hours just just like
walking around this school
and finding all these little details
almost looks like uh some like a comet
over here or a fireball
and then this one over here there's
something below on the gryffindor side
too that almost looks like some kind of
face or i'm sorry the uh hufflepuff side
over here
almost looks like some kind of face
oh my goodness you guys we had rookwood
in here earlier now we got ran rock in
the chat
ran rock how's it going my friend
are you working to get more dark wizards
to your cause
so yeah guys this we thought this was
going to be the big news i mean i
thought we were going to be talking
mostly about this tonight
but then we got more news today
so let's jump back here
and we're going to talk more about the
delay we're going to talk more about the
date and all that too
but i want to start off here at the
beginning hit all of the big news
because uh maybe you've been working all
day you haven't been on social media or
anything yet
but we got another big news drop guys
for hogwarts legacy well i guess it's
not a news drop yet but it's we know
there's one coming
we know there's one coming
so jeff keeley don't miss an exclusive
new look at hogwarts legacy during
gamescom opening night live next tuesday
august 23rd now for my friends in the us
it's not going to be night for you it's
going to be afternoon for us
but um it will be night for the folks in
germany which is where gamescom is but
streaming live so here all the times
this will be my time right here
i am trying to figure out a way to go
stream this you guys
uh 2 p.m is right in the middle of the
workday for me
right in the middle of the workday
so
and i i usually have at my day job i
have a meeting every week on tuesdays at
1pm
so i'm gonna try i mean if i can't swing
it i'm definitely gonna have a reaction
video going up very quickly
yo david thank you so much david for the
donation there i'll be exploring for all
these secret passageways so i'm looking
for the chamber trapdoor on the third
floor etc and more dude jacob
the chamber
a lot of people want to know if we'll be
able to go into the chamber
i my prediction is that we will not be
able to go into it
but i do think
they gotta have some sort of like
chamber easter egg right i mean they
have to have an easter egg for the
chamber of secrets because i mean you
would think we're gonna be able to go to
that bathroom
and we're gonna be able to see the spot
right where the entrance is and it
should be there like the chamber
it would have been built by this time
period you know salazar slytherin way
way way before this
so it will definitely be there
but david thank you so much for the
support and i'm gonna be right there
with you dude right there with you
i mean i just honestly i can't wait when
this game comes out all of the content
that we're going to see
that's why i'm so glad sometimes people
come into the chat and they say hey i
only watch you for hogwarts legacy and
while i i appreciate the sentiment i'm
like support the other creators please
there are so many good hogwarts legacy
creators because when this game drops
guys when this game comes out
there are going to be so many
so many amazing videos coming out i mean
you're going to have lore videos you're
going to have
guide videos dylan with the super chat
as well the 10 super chat dylan thank
you so much
we got to get to that question here uh
but there's gonna be so much incredible
content when you go from lore when you
go from gameplay tips and strategy when
you go to all the secrets then you're
gonna go to all the easter eggs then
you're gonna have i mean you're gonna
have probably like
asmr hogwarts legacy videos or
somebody's just relaxing in the
gryffindor common room and just
monitoring the conversations that may
happen during the day in the common room
hufflepuff common room slytherin
commodore ravenclaw all of them you know
there's going to be so many different
types of these
um so it's it's exciting for sure
but let's see dylan's comment here did
you see troy levitt's comment theory on
why the game was delayed and how the
announcement came about over on wife
once a wife wants a wizard's video
covering the delay no i didn't see that
deal and i hope to check that out
we'll have to pull that up here in a bit
it's literally going to be trending all
year
we can fly anywhere right so we can fly
around uh on and around the quidditch
pitch use your imagination
potential game of the year thought of
turning my console to play hogwarts legs
for the first time gives me chills right
logan right
james i'll go to you for updates
i appreciate it james i do i appreciate
it
but yeah man there there's so many good
uh creators out there lots of good
hogwarts stuff t-moon hey thank you for
subbing to the channel t-moon
all right we gotta go and uh let's see
if we can find this
i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna try to find the comment that
dylan was talking about there
wife once a wizard
oh wait did uh did wife once wizard do a
video on the delay i'm not seeing one
and it's probably not gonna like let you
link it dylan because i think it
automatically kicks out the links
would it have been a wife once a
wizard's most recent video which was
about
let's see a disturbingly
oh wife once a wizard hasn't posted a
video in a while it looks like
oh here's one three days ago but it's
about uh
the dating scene in hogwarts legacy
ah here we go found it i think this is
the one
see if that you can let me know if this
is the uh
oh yeah it'll say dating scene gotcha
gotcha all right so wife what's wizard
hey speaking of the hogwarts legacy
creators here you go check out wife wins
a wizard so this was on their video
about hogwarts legacy the dating scene
which was just posted a few days ago but
yeah troy levitt with the comment oh
this oh oh
we going in deep here okay okay okay
let's go i have not seen this
so i'm gonna be reacting to this in real
time for you guys all right so troy
levitt
catching everybody up who if you don't
know who troy levitt is he previously
worked at avalanche was there for
several years and was there for a lot of
hogwarts legacy's development um
there's a whole big thing on
what happened with him and uh video game
journalists found some stuff on him from
the past
and
basically tried to ruin the guy
uh and so
he ended up leaving uh south from
everything troy said it was nothing to
do with wb that he had some family stuff
he needed to take care of and he's like
you know what now's a good time so he
walked away but this was an inside uh he
was inside avalanche at one point so he
would definitely have some knowledge so
he says i'm no longer an insider to
avalanche but having worked there from
2003 to yeah 2021 there you go and
having been a part of many game launches
i have some speculations about what
happened here oh let's go all right
first thing to note chandler is likely
not involved at all in determining press
marketing or release dates a thousand
percent agree with him right here a
thousand percent
he's not making decisions on things like
this rather he's reacting to them his
job is to communicate the decisions and
dates to the community after they've
been decided upon he's the messenger not
the originator uh he is not an enviable
he is not i think he meant to say in or
he is not in an enviable position to be
in
yeah basically the position chandler's
in not not an enviable spot to be in
that bn although i think he's doing a
great job so far yeah
i've been saying this for a while man
when chandler first took over it was
like people just thought the marketing
floodgates were going to be opened it's
like no no no
um chandler's likely not involved in the
dec and this is nothing against chandler
you know
i work in marketing i mentioned this a
couple times nothing to do with video
games but i work in marketing and
anytime you have an announcement of
anything you know it goes to the people
that are actually
the marketers they're they're just gonna
tell people about it they're gonna
spread the word they're not involved
with the actual most in most cases you
know it's not the marketing people who
are building the game they can't say uh
we're gonna need more time you know
they're not the ones who say that so i
think that's what troy's getting at here
my guess is that there have like likely
been discussions about the probability
of a delay going on behind the scenes
for weeks if not months i'm confident
that nobody anywhere within wb wanted to
delay the release
especially since they're pushing it out
of the very lucrative christmas buying
season on the financial side there may
have been some epic boardroom arguments
weighing the pros and cons of a delay
versus an on-time holiday release ooh i
could see that too because you know the
the people who
don't understand kind of the
nitty-gritty of the game development
they're like
we got to get this out you know let's
get this out holiday season
on the dev side a delay also screws up
all of their holiday plans as well many
of them will now have to work long hours
over the thanksgiving and christmas
breaks oh man
rather than having them off on the pr
marketing manufacturing and distribution
sites
they now have all the problems
associated with informing the various
vendors and buyers and press associates
of the delay too yeah this is why i
never put stock into the
we were all reading the tea leaves on
the uh the hogwarts legacy art book you
know it's like
guys the art book stuff
can change at the drop of a hat
with all these factors previously
triangulated on a holiday release which
is likely why we saw all the art book
stuff starting to kind of form around
that december 3rd
yo james coming in with the
1999 super chat james thank you so much
james we will get to your question in
just a moment but dude thank you so much
for supporting the stream supporting the
channel
that is awesome as soon as we uh i've
got your comment it's highlighted in
orange for me here so as soon as we
finish reading this from troy here we
will answer this
uh but troy says let's see
with all these factors yeah there would
have been a tremendous pressure to just
stick to the date and release the game
even if it wasn't quote fully ready
close quote which with the intent to
patch out the problems in the weeks and
months after the release indeed if wb
and the dev team didn't genuinely care
they may have just given in to the
inertia and released it as good enough
to satisfy their targets and obligations
but someone or more likely a coalition
of someone's took a stand and convinced
the consensus within the wb organization
that delaying the game for qualitative
reasons was even more important than all
those other things and i applaud the
courage it took to recognize and then
champion that position
but even once the coalition for quality
had convinced the internal organization
to delay a new release date had to be
determined and i'm sure that turned into
a whole other big decision-making
process how long of a delay what's the
new release date and how does the delay
impact the 10 million other moving parts
involved in bringing a game to market
i don't know for certain but i bet they
didn't settle on the february 10 day
until very recently they probably had
weeks of prior discussion over figuring
out this date too
i think this is why we didn't get an
announcement until now i've
i heard a while back behind the scenes
that the game was probably not going to
release this year
i didn't really talk about it much
but but that the person who told me that
they really weren't sure
how long of a delay was going to be or
anything like that so
i totally see this as the case and i
think the reason avalanche people kept
saying well if that's the case why
wouldn't avalanche they should announce
it right away
i think they wanted to wait until they
had a firm date is what i think
so my guess is that our new target
release date has been known internally
by wwe and the dev team itself for a
very short time themselves maybe only
about a week again that's a guess and
not confirmed but if true explains a lot
all right home stretch here it would
mean that chandler himself may not have
known of the new date until earlier this
past week he may have been instructed by
his supervisors to scramble together an
announcement by friday that would have
given him precious little time to figure
out how best to do that if so it would
explain the lack of thursday content in
favor of the friday announcement yes a
bigger release date event would have
been preferable but if i'm right that
the february 10th date was decided upon
recently the wb team would want to get
that word out just as soon as possible
they wouldn't want it to leak out which
it definitely would as soon as they
started telling the vendors and thereby
create a bunch of confusion while they
fussed about getting some big new
presentation ready just to confirm the
new date how unceremonious would it have
been to learn the date next week via a
gamestop flyer or something hey
troy come on now we need to get our
youtube views up we wouldn't have
complained about that
a quick realignment no i prefer it this
way too honestly much better this way a
quick realignment of date target is
critical especially since the announce
delay is relatively short wb would want
to snap things into clarity for vendors
press and fans alike after they decided
on a new date waiting two or three more
weeks to announce it would have come
with risks and challenges of its own
in this context friday's announcement
looks to me like the team handled things
as quickly directly frankly and honestly
as they could i think chandler's little
walk and talk on the fourth floor patio
was very well done given all this my
take is that chandler and his community
team have all sorts of cool things lined
up to show i bet you get that alleged
summer asmr video this coming week but
that they were forced into reacting to
the new date on short notice and hints
were forced to reschedule what they
originally had planned
in short i think you'll be back to
salivating over the awesome very soon
wait when did he post this three days
ago so that was before we got the big uh
gamescom news
all right lots to break down there let's
get to james's question though james
sorry about the delay thank you again
for the support do you think the deathly
hallows will be in the game where do you
think they will be hidden i can see them
being part of some tougher challenges
post main story so james i don't know a
couple weeks ago i would have said
probably not
but because of some recent things
starting with let me pull this back up
here because
oh let me go into my hogwarts legacy
folder here
because of this right here we talked
about this on our last live stream uh
james
this was part of the autodesk
presentation now of course just in terms
of being physical like being existing in
the world
absolutely the deathly hallows should be
out there somewhere right it's just a
matter of how will they weave into the
story will they weave into the story
will it be more like an easter egg kind
of thing will it be something we only
hear rumors about or hear students
talking about or will it actually factor
into the story i think that's the big
question
so this right here we still aren't 100
sure
what the mcmbh means could mean
something character mannequin mannequin
bust
something to do with that but the fact
that that the term deathly hallows
appears in their file names
to me at the very least
very least says we're getting deathly
hallows easter eggs
so like something about a hint of a very
powerful wand or the resurrection stone
or even even if it's just something as
simple as the deathly hallows emblem
that we can get for our clothing
so i think they will at least be in the
game from that point of view
in terms of actually being able to get
and use them
that would be more complicated it'd be
awesome
but given that those play such a key
role because i think we could probably
we could probably figure out where most
of them
should be
i would have to kind of look at the
harry potter lexicon and harry potter
wiki and read up on some things
but um i think we could figure out where
they should be
at the time period or at least where
they could potentially be given the time
period
because the peverell brothers were
actually
for some reason in my mind i always
think about them being like way back
with
gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw and
slytherin but they actually came much
later i was i can't remember what i was
reading up on this past week
um oh it was it was um it was relating
to
this right here it was relating to this
picture and trying to figure out these
different magical items here
so i would say there's a pretty high
chance that the deathly hallows are at
least mentioned in the game
and i don't know maybe uh
i'll say maybe like a 25 chance that
they
factor into the story somehow
that's what i'll go with james
all right
dylan had to hop out hey dylan thanks
for stopping by and thanks for pointing
out that uh
article to me or not article but choice
comment there as well appreciate it
johnny thank you subscribed as well
johnny thank you so much apologies if i
if i missed that
10 42 a.m for mighty destroyer nice clue
viewer welcome back clue
i would imagine they are mentioned uh as
an easter egg because them actually
playing into the story could easily
interfere with the canon yeah that's the
thing maddie right if you
that's why i never thought dumbledore
would play a huge role and why i thought
they would kind of stay away from some
of the bigger name characters is because
it's like
then you really start to get into the
canon stuff of like affecting what we
know so they chose a time period i mean
they've even talked about they chose it
for that specific reason so they would
have some freedom to explore
uh in terms of you know
building in this world building their
own storylines within this world yeah
yeah no problem james thank you
so this uh all the stuff from troy here
is very interesting as someone who
you know regardless of of you know how
much you think he knows or how you feel
about troy or whatever i mean the fact
is he was at avalanche for a long time
and he knows that side of game
development
what do you got what did you guys think
about the actual announcement of um the
delay
brandon subscribing as well brandon
welcome because i saw some people on
reddit kind of complaining that
sort of what troy was kind of alluding
to there that it felt like very scrapped
together and was like
come on that's it you know you just walk
out and then i saw other people saying
like oh i loved you know i thought this
was very like warm and personal and not
just the corporate
you know the black the black square with
the white text of like the game has been
delayed
our new release date is i mean because
on one hand it is exciting that we're
getting a firm date like like that part
is
exciting
let's see what some of the comments here
got your money's worth out of that
comment
that's funny
a more poet says i really don't want the
deathly hallows in the game i think the
character model character model thing is
just an emblem to display that you're a
seeker like lovegood said in the books
yeah because he like uh
he wore he had the little uh necklace
right
definitely owls were created in 13th
century yeah deathly hallows were
oh yeah so 13th century but then
gryffindor ravenclaw hufflepuff and
slytherin lived like
medieval times i want to say let's see
uh godric
gryffindor
dates
yeah
993.
this is what it said
pre-976 so they were like way see i like
in my head when i retail of the three
brothers i always just like
it always felt like that was a
you know
even further back than it really was
delay's a part of business whether
that's video games or for example
construction absolutely yeah
absolutely
yeah apologies guys i'm i'm not sure i'm
seeing a couple comments that are
getting like retracted i'm not sure
what's going on there there's a couple
of auto
it'll always if you're trying to post a
link it won't let you post a link and
then there are some some words that it
won't let you post as well so just maybe
try to reword it or
if it's a link you might just want to
uh just kind of tell me tell me where it
is instead of posting the exact link
i hope the npcs feel alive like real
people kind of like how red dead
redemption 2 npcs behave
easy to say the game is uh in a good
place so no one should be worried about
two months
right yeah they they were pre-merlin
which is just like insane to think about
hey jon snow welcome
hints of the holy grail appearing in the
game i feel like i remember reading
something about that
maybe on the harry potter game subreddit
we got the nose of sauron dude we got
the nose of sauron in here we got ran
rock was in here earlier rookwood was in
here earlier now we got jon snow in here
as well
oh we had zachary morrison here where's
frodo where's frodo baggins
opinion on the merlin morgana theory
it's fun uh i think it's fun theory
i think it
i think it makes a lot of sense
but then there's also part of me that
says we've had so much time
on our hands
and i love james expecto go he's the one
who uh
i shouldn't say he's the one who started
it i feel like he's where i first heard
somebody really driving in on the merlin
and morgana theory maybe he was the one
who who started it but
i don't know like like with merlin i
feel more confident about merlin because
we have confirmation that
there are at least puzzles from merlin
in the game we know that 100 sure you
know we know that there are puzzles of
merlin in the game we also know that
merlin his name appears on the stained
glass in professor benz's classroom
history of magic
so that one i feel a little more
confident that merlin is going to have
some role in the game
the question is how big is the role and
does it play a major part in the story
the morgana stuff i'm not nearly as sold
on
not nearly as sold on that frodo's
nightly nerd what's up frodo in the
hufflepuff common room
i mean that makes sense for frodo to
want to go to the hufflepuff common room
for sure
uh jordan considering the game was
developed mostly during the previous
generations time safe to assume the game
will run okay on ps4 and xbox
that's like the million dollar question
well i guess the million dollar question
would more be like what the switch
versus gonna look like i would think so
yeah i mean
i don't know if it's something about
if it says more about the ps4 and that
generation or if it says more about the
current generation that we're in but
ps4 and xbox um one you know those were
so close to getting like like the
architecture not saying they were as
powerful as gaming pcs but like the
architecture was so close to being like
pcs now
so i feel like developers have a much
better handle now of being able to
to scale games and i mean now we're
seeing games developed across like
spider-man for example big bang theory
shelter a shelter thank you for the sub
we're seeing um
like like spider-man for example it was
on ps4 it was on ps5 and then they just
brought it out for pc as well so
uh you know it ran the gamut in terms of
being on all this different now that
again that game
that came uh as a result of several
years and you know it started the ps4
and then they had time to upgrade that
one for the ps5 and then they've
upgraded on the pc
uh so yeah i would think the ps4
um and xbox one versions will run fine
the big question is going to be how how
will it run on switch i think because a
lot of people
are still wanting to know what's going
on with that version
a because they they didn't announce the
date for it
uh and from what i've heard there are
some nintendo typically takes longer
than the others to
i don't know some sort of certification
process that the games go through when
it uh when it comes to you know
sending the final digital version for
like to go on the digital store and
everything
so i don't know i don't know if this
means the switch version is having
problems or if it's just more of like a
nintendo side of things i think
so that i mean that much remains to be
seen but
yeah the switch one i really want to
find out more about that like if i if i
was advising people right now which one
to get
if you have a ps5 or series x i would
probably lean that way if you have a
gaming pc of course that's going to be
an option too the thing about that
if you if you have
if you have the option of both like if
you have a ps5
an xbox series x or an xbox series x or
a gaming pc
that would you really want to kind of
pay attention as the game gets closer
to see how it's performing on all three
of them
because there there have been some weird
surprises like people a lot of people
online and in comments they'll just say
oh pc is going to be way better of
course
the the correct way of saying that is
the pc version
should
should
run the best
but as as we have seen and and i know
this because i
i heard that for years and then one day
i built a gaming pc and then i started
to see oh
yeah it's pretty awesome most of the
time
but there's a lot of little things that
can go wrong too and then you have games
come out like elden ring which i have no
idea what state elden ring is in now on
on the pc but um digital foundry if you
want to look into stuff like this
digital foundry they're the go-to for
this they do a great job
but they actually recommended the xbox
series x version of
elden ring
over the pc version and and that's like
top of the line pc version and that it
wasn't because pc bad it was because the
elden ring wasn't as optimized for the
pc as it was for the consoles it didn't
run as well it had more i think it was
stuttering or something and the reason
they recommended the xbox series x over
the ps5 is because ps5 did not have
vr yet so i know we're getting way
technical now
um but now ps5 has vrr so it's it's more
on par and i have no idea what's
happened with the with the pc version of
elder ring if it's if they solved all
that
over time you know you would think they
will but in terms of like launch that
best experience if you're somebody who
has the means to get you know
any of the any of those
then you know i would i would kind of
wait and see
um console though ps5 is going to have
the uh the dual sense features
even as a ps5 owner i'm not an xbox guy
but even as a ps5 owner that's not
enough of a reason i don't think um so i
would say you know
ps5 or xbox series x
i would probably rate right up there
with pc until we know more about how the
game runs then i would say ps4
then i would say xbox one
and then i would say on switch i just
have no idea
i just have no idea steam deck might be
an interesting case study as well but we
again we just don't know anything about
steam deck or switch at this point like
if it will be optimized for steam deck
how well it's going to run on steam deck
we don't know any of that the switch one
i mean because if the switch one
if it just runs like decent you know it
doesn't even have to have all the bells
and whistles the other ones the biggest
advantage of the switch is the
portability right it's the portability
and it's like the most affordable
console
and one thing i want to point out here
is um
they did not put xbox series s on here
i don't know if it was just a rush thing
and they forgot but they did confirm on
twitter that xbox series s
will be included within the release for
all these so that was not a i don't
think it was intentional for them to
leave the series s version off so if
i would honestly i would probably even
recommend the series s version over the
switch at this point just because
we just don't know i mean we just we
just don't know
and to be fair we don't know how it's
going to run across any of these
platforms right now so
classic says coming from an xbox series
x user 100 the ps5 will have the best
experience in my opinion
been a pc camera my entire life i can't
use a controller say my really that's
fascinating poet
why would anyone want to play a game
like hogwarts legacy on switch
can switch even support this i mean see
i've
there's a really interesting thing tater
with hogwarts legacy
um
i have seen
i don't know that i would say i would
yeah i would say i'd feel comfortable
saying a lot podcast now and i talked
about this i was on uh alex's live
stream
i guess what like a week or so ago now
and we talked about this hogwarts legacy
is in a really interesting spot because
there are a lot of people
who
are saying that they don't normally play
games
but they were fans of harry potter
growing up
and this was a game they'd always
dreamed of and they'd always imagine
and they they want to get into they want
to buy this game even though they're not
big gamers
and so
that i feel like is where we're getting
a lot of switch questions because people
are like and i mean switch is an
incredibly dominant console in terms of
the sales numbers
jon snow rules yo with the super chat
thank you so much jon snow i think this
will be the beginning of something big
dude i hope so
i hope so i saw a question earlier about
how do i think hogwarts legacy will end
um i wouldn't i think they meant like
story wise
however it ends i think it's i hope they
set up for a second game
i hope they set up for a second game i
really do
that is my hope in terms of story i mean
i think we'll have a some sort of
resolution to the
goblin
and um
the goblin rebellion like that conflict
and the conflict with the magical
creatures
some sort of resolution to that
and then i think there's something i
mean the ancient magic stuff
will definitely get some kind of
resolution to that but that one to me
feels big enough i mean that that feels
like that's going to be the core plot of
this game is this this ancient magic
that
ran rock and who knows how many other
potential wizards
or other beings are after this power we
just don't know yet
this game will sell consoles right
exactly i think and i think sony
probably recognized that
and that's probably why they wanted the
marketing
exclusivity for it
what do they do for the sequels jared uh
i think the sequel would set up for a
year six
so we're year five in this game i do not
think it's going to be more than one
year i think it's going to take place
over one school year
and set up for a potential year six and
then if they want i mean they've set up
perfectly for a trilogy because then
they could do year seven
and if you deliver three incredible
games like we're getting way ahead of
ourselves now they've got to get the
first one out
it's got to be well received it's going
to sell well it's got to be well
received to sell even more
because they're going to get that
initial sales no doubt but if the game
bombs and everybody's like ah it kind of
sucks
then it's not going to get that you know
snowball effect like more and more
people hearing about it more and more
people talking about it
um but if it get if it's a solid game
and i'm not saying like it needs to be a
nine or ten i'm saying if it's like a
solid seven or eight
to me that's gonna warrant a sequel and
that's gonna get a lot of uh excited
harry potter fans playing it and wanting
another one so i think it would set up
for year six year seven and then my
dream i mean my dream game after after
if this delivers my next idea for a
dream like harry potter game would be
like you're in your wizarding career at
that point
you're like um
i know a lot of people want an mmo i
think that'd be an interesting route to
explore
but i want to be an rr man i want us to
like could you imagine the type of game
you could build around
having a it doesn't even have to be the
character in hogwarts legacy it could be
completely like just just new wizard you
introduce that is like
working in the aura office and i don't
know set it wherever you want set it way
after harry potter when harry potter's
long gone or said it said it before set
it after hogwarts legacy if you want but
then anything they do after like because
like if they go to year seven
then you gotta bring dumbledore
then dumbledore has to get into the
story and when you bring dumbledore into
the story
well now all of a sudden you're treading
on very i mean you have to be very very
careful at that point because you're
you're dealing with a major character
who is involved in the all of the
mainline harry potter books obviously
and then he's heavily involved in
fantastic beasts so all of the
harry potter
media going right now i guess with the
exception of cursed child
um
dumbledore plays like a major role in
and i mean i guess he's got he's got
somewhat of a role in
cursed child too but but definitely a
huge role in in fantastic beasts
[Music]
don't know what to get it on xbox series
x or pc what do you think is the best
choice see that's the one i think we
just don't know yet like
the pc people would yell at me like out
in my in my mind i i feel like console
is is going to be the safer choice right
there
uh guess who i feel like your xbox would
be the safer choice but really there's
no reason to make a choice yet i mean if
you want to pre-order it fine i'm not
one of those people who says
do not pre-order anything i haven't even
pre-ordered the game yet myself because
i'm waiting to see if there's going to
be a collector's edition
i would pre-order for that but otherwise
i mean if you feel like uh there's no
reason to pre-order then
don't pre-order mr vette hey thank you
for the sub mr vet appreciate it
retro elite gamer with the sub as well
retro
i like your name dude i like your name
thanks for the sub
but yeah i i would lean toward xbox
unless you hear
as the game gets closer and you see
somebody like digital foundry do the
breakdown and they're like
the pc version just runs incredible and
the series x version is not that great
it also depends on where you uh i know
some people play like
this is one thing a lot of people don't
think about in this discussion
think about your monitor and your tv
like some people play at their desk they
have their console set up plugged into
the same monitor that your pc is plugged
up into for you it's not a big deal but
if your console's plugged up into a tv
and then your pc is plugged up into a
monitor well your monitor makes a big
difference too like i'm running into a
big thing now where like
i finally saved up and got myself an
oled tv
wanted an oled tv for years and i got an
oled tv
and so now like i used to hook my ps5 up
to my uh
monitor here but my monitor is like a
1080
24 inch monitor i'm like oh
i tried playing ratchet clank on here
the other day and it just looks so bad
compared to my 4k tv right there
so and i know the pc will be saying well
you could plug in your you know plug it
in there but yeah then i gotta run the
wire all the way over there it's just
it's it's a whole big thing
but yeah i would just keep uh keep an
eye out for digital foundry and stuff
like that as it gets closer d jane thank
you so much for the super chat d jane
what are your thoughts on being an
animagus
in the game
i mean my thoughts on rb would be that i
would love it i just can't see how they
could pull it off though
because unless there was like a set
animal
and then that would just make people mad
wouldn't it
like
if there was a set animal that it's like
okay this is the animal that our
character
everybody should even though everybody's
like their own character they can make
their character look like whatever they
want sound like whatever they want but
the animagus has to be the same for
everybody
that's the only way i think they could
pull it off maybe if they had it where
you could like choose between two or
three
but and then even then people would just
get upset and the reason i think it
would be so hard is because when you
turn into an animal all of a sudden you
have so many different abilities so that
would really i mean they would have to
have gameplay sections designed
for you being able to traverse
and then they're like if you can just
turn into an eagle
well then you're going to be able to
completely skip over some obstacles that
other people would have to
to take on so the only way i could see
it happening is if they actually um
just picked one animal but i would say
pretty low sadly
yo nico with the super chat
pc version opens the door to modding
yes
yes
that that is the big that is a big one
in the pc's
cap right there
if if you were at all interested in the
potential for mods
then pcs really actually i remember xbox
doing something with mods a few years
ago i don't know if that ever took off
or not i'm i'm not an xbox guy so i have
no idea like how difficult it was to get
set up or anything but
um
but yeah if you uh are at all interested
in that then pc is obviously the way to
go and
the potential for mods in this game oh
my god i mean they're through the roof
they're through the roof they're they're
going to be mods people always say i
hope avalanche will support mods like
they don't have to support it they will
be mods now if they're smart and they do
if they do support it then the mod
should be even better like if they
really embrace the modding community as
we've seen you know other games do and
uh really goes a long way in helping
them out i think that would be great
but they also might want to leave things
open for the sequel you know
but dude thank you so much for the super
chat supporting the channel both of you
though those recent super chats very
much appreciated
i saw somebody asking about um
a theory
dot wife wants a wizard's dog theory i
haven't i haven't uh seen that theory
anybody want to try to sum it up
uh america the the official release date
is february 10th 2023
dlc for the game greg russell asking do
i think they'll release dlc
i think if it sells if the game sells
well enough and they have a good launch
yes
i think they all but confirm they are
wanting to do dlc in the playstation
blog post i mean they all but said it
they they said they wanted to do more
in this world
so i i definitely think so if it does
well
same goes for patronus can we choose do
we get a random one everyone have the
same one yeah that's a good point too
the thing about the patronus though is i
do feel like they could have more
animals because
there's one purpose of a patronus you
know so it would just be a matter of
programming the animations
that's not really going to affect
gameplay as much right because the
patronus is a very specific use case you
use it to fend off
dementors so it's not like and i guess
you could you know
we saw them in uh deathly hallows and
other harry potter books start to use it
uh to send messages patronuses can be
used to send messages
i don't think they would use that for
this game maybe they would i don't know
but but again it's like it's a very
specific task whereas like
if i'm at a challenge where there's a
body of water and i have to like solve
this puzzle to get through it
well if i'm an animagus and i could just
transform into an eagle then i could
just fly right over right
or if he could transform into some water
creature so but patronus
i i oh because we did see dementors in
the game so if in that first trailer
although they haven't they didn't show
any in the second trailer speaking of
trailers though
see this is what happens you guys always
ask such good questions i could just
like start answering all the questions
and we just have a good time that way
but i want to make sure
i want to make sure we talk about
the other big news guys
and we talked about it a little bit but
i want to i i said speaking of trailers
we got to talk about this this gamescom
gamescom thing man
what do you guys think we're going to
see
because i
go right here to chandler woods twitter
account here because chandler's been
dropping some uh not even really hints
basically just like
trying to be as forthcoming as he can
so i want to go to
first let's go to
this one right here
so this was from today he said one week
excited for you all to see what we've
been cooking up so he talks about the uh
he shared jeff keeley's post now there's
been another couple of posts from
channel recently
i'll tell you what i think it's going to
be
let me scroll through here and i don't i
haven't seen anybody talk about this
so he had this one this not this i'll
get to the other part in a second what i
haven't seen anybody talking about but
uh he says today is a huge day getting
to reveal the release
release date however this still isn't
the cool stuff to show you later this
summer i mentioned earlier this year
lots more to come
lots more to come
guys
you're a wizard harry
stefan tias
hey thank you for subscribing to the
channel welcome
so lots more dude that
i mean i think we're gonna get
i'll say i'm shocked by the gamescom
thing
because i
thought i thought that it was only
i was expecting it was going to
um
have to be at a playstation event just
because everywhere we've seen hogwarts
legacy so far it's been at a big
playstation event
so this one's a little bit surprising to
me i have a pleasant surprise but it's a
little bit of a surprise so i think
we're still going to get hogwarts legacy
i mean obviously this one's confirmed
for gamescom but i still think we're
going to get it at
whatever sony's next big event is this
year too
uh and i think whenever they finally
announce the collector's editions
i think we'll get a big playstation blog
post
i would hope so anyway
um a big post about that
but in terms of uh what i specifically
think we're gonna see let me keep
scrolling back
let me keep scrolling back
so it could be a little trailer
could be a long trailer with game play
maybe is it a gameplay demo are they
actually going to walk us through the
mission let me know most oh i have no i
always forget to do a poll i'm going to
do a poll right now this is super fun
let's do it let's do a poll right now so
what would you most like to see from
hogwarts
legacy at
gamescom
all right so first option would be
uh let's see the character creator
the second one would be
um combat
breakdown
i'm gonna say story trailer
and then what's one more we could say
character so character creator
that's the thing a lot of people want to
see combat breakdown story trailer oh
here's a good one um
class
explanation
or um how should i word this
explanation
or i'm just gonna say how classes work
or classes breakdown
so what i mean by classic classes
breakdown is like how exactly they're
gonna
how are we you know do we how does the
timing in the game work right how does
all that work
all right let's see how this works ask
your community all right there you go
guys
you can vote in the poll there
vote in the poll let's see what you guys
think
because here's what i think this is just
my guess and i haven't had a lot of time
to
think about it yet but if you remember
back after the autodesk
session
chandler posted about the
abraham ronan
oh wait here's the one where he okay so
i went back too far this is the one
where he said i've seen some excitement
around our autodesk
session set expectations okay so then it
should be shortly after this then
let's see chandler chandler chandler
dude where was the post
i must have just been talking as i was
scrolling
here it is okay yeah
so this was after the autodesk he says
looks like some of you caught a few new
tidbits in our autodesk presentation yes
our charms professor is abraham ronan
and as many of you guessed he's indeed a
slytherin
but then after that
this is the thing i haven't seen people
uh anybody bring back up yet the
autodesk presentation gave you a glimpse
of our character creator we are planning
to go into more detail on it later
including showing that mysterious final
tab
i wonder if this is the focus of the
gamescom segment
is this going to be is the character
creator going to be the focus
or are they going to show us
like maybe it starts
with a brief look at the character
creator
and then it goes into
an actual gameplay section because i
almost put as one of the options
in the poll to see a mission but then i
knew everybody would pick that
because that would show so much right i
mean that would be all that would be my
number one thing is if we could see
a mission from not start to finish
because you wouldn't want to give away
everything but
but just like
a few brief moments of a mission like
maybe our character accepting a mission
and then it cuts to us like
going out and doing you know whatever
that that mission is
and then it cuts to us returning to the
character completing the the mission or
whatever
oh my goodness you guys are they're
close 30 right now saying classes
breakdown
22 and dude the three-way tie right now
are you kidding me
are you kidding me we're at 113 likes by
the way guys if you're uh checking out
the stream and having a good time and
you have not yet hit that thumbs up
button go ahead and hit that now that
will help more people find this live
stream who might be interested in
hogwarts legacy he might be interested
in hanging out with us
checking out the channel so yeah it's
like right now it's 33 of you
are saying classes breakdown
22
are saying story trailer 22 combat
trailer 22 character creator okay
character creator just got a slight bump
up to 23 but wow what would you most
like to see
i'm gonna screenshot this and send it to
chandler and be like well
you can't please everybody unless you're
showing all four of these things
i think if i had to pick
oh man which two would i pick or which
what would be my number one thing i'd
want to see if i had to choose between
these
character creator i don't care about
that nearly as much as everyone else
seems to
i mean i don't care whatever i'll play
as any character i i don't even care if
it looks like me you know it doesn't
have to look like me it doesn't have to
sound like me
as long as i can be a student in
hogwarts whatever tall short
dark hair no hair
it's all good with me so that one i'm
not as concerned about
combat breakdown
that's i'm going to say that one for now
story trailer
i'm torn on that one because i really
don't want to see much more of the story
i really i just i don't want to see that
much more of the story you know
i mean that's the kind of thing that
keep it under wraps
there's there's no need new store says i
want to see a story trailer
yeah i mean i i would enjoy seeing it
but they just got to be careful with the
story like don't give away too much you
know
don't give away too much right now we're
still asking so many questions about the
story
which i i think is good i think that's
healthy to have like for us to be
curious about it if we have all the
answers you know that's
that's not fun
classes break down
i think i agree with you guys too that
one's at the top of my list
so if i had i would i would have to pick
between combat and between classes
oh man that's tough
that's tough
i'm gonna say
if i had to pick just one i think i
would say the classes
because that to me
would help us figure out the the
structure of the game
because that's gonna be such a crucial
part right
like that will be such a crucial part of
how the game is going to
methodically play out you know like like
what the what the day-to-day at hogwarts
is like
that's that's going to be fascinating
uh frustrated player so the songs
playing
are from a no copyright
i'll post the uh i posted it earlier in
the chat i'll share it again here
it's just a youtube it's called celtic
medieval tavr music
non-copyright
volume three here you go
unsung hero would love to see character
select creation forbidden forest gamepl
yeah we talked we did talk about that at
the beginning i agree it would have been
a fantastic time to release
but i think the reasoning is sound and i
think i mean if
it results in a better game then
i think it's worth it um it's not a huge
delay you know it's roughly two months i
think most thought it was going to
release early december so now we go
january february so two months not too
bad if it gets pushed beyond that then i
think that's gonna start to open up
a lot more
troublesome questions i think
all right i'll give it another a couple
minutes on the poll guys if you haven't
had a chance to vote in it go ahead and
uh vote on it now what would you most
like to see from hogwarts legacy at
gamescom if you uh are just getting in
for the night and you haven't checked up
on the news today guys we got
confirmation that hogwarts legacy will
have a presence at gamescom i did see a
chat question earlier and i um i saw it
and didn't get a chance to answer it but
somebody was asking about
when is the uh announcement supposed to
happen we don't know that's the thing
about these shows i think it's scheduled
to be uh
let me see if jeff keeley actually
posted
let's see if he posted about
what the uh
i think it's a two hour show
and if it's a two-hour show we have no
idea
yeah two hours
so here it is guys so it's two hour live
show thousands of fans and audience 30
plus games on stage
so that right there should tell us
something right if there's 30 plus games
on stage
and if you guys have ever watched any of
these keeley events before
you know it's not just going to be
non-stop games as much as we would like
for it to be
it's not going to be non-stop games you
know they're going to have other
segments they're going to have things
going on in between they're going to be
adds
just the nature of the beast right
so 30 plus games over the course of
about two hours oh that that kind of
limits things a bit so i think it's
gonna be i think it's gonna be a trailer
i think it's gonna be a new trailer
is my prediction
and maybe we get to see some of those
things that we talked about
it's very calming i know right i'm
loving it i kind of switched it up
tonight because i normally use um
there's like a spotify playlist
uh the harris heller spotify playlist
but i was like man we need something to
fit the
need something to fit the fantasy vibe
here
maddie feels like classes are gonna be
set quests you can start at any moment
and it just skips to the appropriate
time like in red dead too
could be could be
high iq warrior i did see that i know
you were asking somebody else i did see
that i haven't had a chance to really
i don't even know if they've officially
said like what
what all that's about yet because it
kind of sounded like a vr thing and then
somebody was saying no it's probably
more like going to those
mobile things
if you want combat are you expecting an
entire button layout too with classes
wanting them to reveal the day cycle
yeah like the day the day night cycle
and then how we
because i i feel like that's one thing
they really need to clarify because a
lot of people excited about this game
are getting it in their minds of how
classes are going to be
and i've seen a lot of people convinced
it's going to be one way and a lot of
people convinced it's going to be
another way and a lot of people commence
it's going to be another way
and i think there would be i think it's
better to go ahead and uh
kind of rip off the band-aid so to speak
and show people no okay this is how it's
going to be set up because it as i've
talked about on the on this live show
and in my videos and stuff before
you know it it can't just be
monday
at 8 00 a.m you have charms class and at
12 30 you have defense against the
darkhearts i mean that would be too
tedious like to where to where you have
to remember
oh my gosh we got charms coming up and
then this day i've got this class i mean
it'd be like managing classes in the
real world but some people say they want
that i don't think it's going to be that
though i think they're going to have to
simplify it in some way whether it's
like something like what persona does or
i know a lot of people talk about bully
as being a good example but i don't know
if bully would work for it
all right
let's see where the where did the pole
end up here
about the same about the same so 32
percent
i'm gonna go ahead and in actually you
know what i'm gonna screenshot this
first
so i can uh take a look at that later
but yeah 33
said classes breakdown is what they
would most want to see 21 say story
trailer 23 combat breakdown 23 character
creator
nice thank you guys for voting in the
poll there you go
there's the poll completion
good night ellie thanks for hanging out
all right i want to go back up
man see you guys just ask so many good
questions
that i see them and then like i make a
mental note to go back to them but then
by the time i'm ready to go back to it
there's like another good question
that's been asked
uh somebody asked about asked about
pre-orders uh yog pre-orders are already
open at least in the us
you can go to amazon best buy game stop
right now and pre-order the game
i'd love to see collector edition
announcements though i think that'd be
awesome but this this doesn't feel like
a collector's edition setting for me
tater thank you so much for the super
chat
very much appreciated tater appreciate
your support of the stream
and the channel feel like classes will
be like mini games quests yeah i think
that's what somebody else was saying
like
so like your charms class
will be like your quest for the day
which is sort of similar to how the old
games handled it
they kind of did a little you know you
had this whole little challenge area
that you would go into
but yeah
i
i don't think it's gonna be like a
challenge area i think it'll be more
i mean they'll have to do something that
like teaches you the application of the
spell and we've already seen that one
little area where because we're a fifth
year it's like we're gonna need the
extra time or whatever and i think it's
um professor ronan is standing there by
us right in front of the game keepers
hut
but again i don't know if that's just
like an extracurricular thing or if
that's the class and we're like having
charms outside for the day
i don't know i don't know
have a uh retro have you heard of the
leak that hogwarts obviously covers
years five through seven and two years
as an aura
i say no way
i say no way
i do i feel like i do remember seeing
that but
i mean that would just be so
yeah i i that's not happening in my
opinion
that i mean i feel like that would be
the
that's like four games right there i
feel like
unl unless the timing is just like
really really sped up you know to where
it's like five hours of gameplay is like
half a year of school or something you
know
oh collect uh that y'all that that might
have been you mentioning collection
edition stuff yeah
mary studios hey mary i just uh just saw
your name pop up good to see you again
glad you're able to stop by and hang out
yeah classes
that i kind of agonized over it for a
bit but that's the one that i would um
that's the one that i would pick two
isn't the event four days it might be
multiple days but i think that keeley
has confirmed hogwarts is is in the
two-hour live show of the opening night
i think
zachary morris with the 999 super chat
dude thank you so much
for your support of the channel man you
guys are going crazy with the super
chats tonight
that's very much appreciated uh zachary
says i think there will be some main
story classes
but you'll be part of a specul special
curriculum designed to help you catch up
yeah right that's what they say in the
trailer yeah be part of a special
curriculum designed to help you catch up
to the other fifth years
this tells us most of the classes
classwork will be side quests ah
okay
so i think there will be some main story
classes
i see what you're saying
yeah because when i was talking with
alex the podcast now he was kind of
under the impression his take is that
some of them will be optional so it's
like if you just she was like you know
what i'm not gonna go to potions
then you're not gonna get to learn this
specific potion
or you can get it in another way like
maybe you can go and uh you go to the
shop and you have to buy it or you have
to like i don't know convince another
student to make it for you or something
i don't know that's going to be like
that i think
i mean like you said some of them are
going to be they have to be required
they're they're cut scenes they're not
going to put a ton of cut scenes in the
game for
completely optional things but at the
same time they're also not going to be
able to put a cut cnn for every single
time you walk into the charms classroom
to take a charms class so yeah zachary
it's a good point about the
the special curriculum so they'll
they're gonna have to balance that
special curriculum
with
i feel like you know what that's a good
point i feel like the special curriculum
that could be the thing
that you go and do anytime
and i that might be what you were you
were getting at there like that's the
thing that's like it's just open you
want to go practice here's where you can
go practice brush up on your skills
i like that i like that and then you
have certain classes that are part of
part of the storyline that you go and
take
machob wants to see the ravenclaw
company right yeah
i really want to see the ravenclaw
opinion too like is that one
they figure out
why exactly were they keeping that one
under under wraps you know is it just so
they have something else to show or is
there like
is there a story reason right
when a 10-minute asmr video walking
around the school no comment yeah could
you imagine
and it's interesting in that in that big
uh
reply that we read from troy it sounded
and again he's not in avalanche anymore
so perhaps he
it sounded like he was just guessing but
it sounds like he thinks the asmr a
summer asmr video is very likely
which i feel like that one is just
i mean that's got to be about to drop
soon right
or maybe there maybe they're saving that
for when they know they're going to have
like a a lull of not really any big news
i mean because the asmr thing that's
something but if they drop to something
i mean we're getting close to the end of
summer you know
and if they have a summer asmr
that's really going to make me rethink
seasons and how
because like if there's a summer in the
game
well i guess that would make sense
because august september
a little bit of september is still
summer and you start hogwarts september
1st
but then if you get to the end of the
year
it would have to be more than a year
unless or they're only going to have
like a few weeks of
summer you know
but it's all it's going to be all about
how they they choose to progress the
story you know
they control how fast the days go you
know it's not gonna be a real word real
world clock coconut head gotta head out
hey coconut thank you for stopping by
and hanging out
dude it amazes me how fast these go by
we've already been going an hour and a
half
i usually only say i'm like okay
i'm gonna go for about two hours and
then it's like two and a half hours when
i finally realized
mary mary wants to know if we're only
having four companies or for getting
more yeah i want to know that too
ethan good question so i'm working on
i'm starting
kind of like a weekly email newsletter
or blog type thing
things that like don't really fit into
videos and are probably too long for
twitter hey ethan thank you for the sub
as well appreciate it
and that's one thing that i'm working on
right now
so if you guys don't follow me on
twitter at retrorecontour follow me
there and keep an eye out for that
for that newsletter but um i'll give you
guys a preview of it now since you're
here i don't think it was anything to do
with with marketing
i don't i don't think it was anything to
do with avoiding god of war
i don't think they would have released
the same day as god of war or even the
same week or two of god of war just
because it's you know
it's not good business sense but
releasing three weeks
four weeks five weeks you know a month
later
nah that's that's totally fine
the audience yes it has a very similar
audience to god of war but it also has a
different enough audience to stand on
its own i don't think that anything to
do with it
my source that i talked to who told me
several weeks ago that things were
heading in this direction
they said it's just a matter of
avalanche kind of overestimated what
they could do and and um
in in terms of qa quality assurance
bug fixing so they are very much in that
stage right now guys they're very much
in that phase i saw somebody earlier um
and i totally meant to reply to this and
didn't but um
i think it was before we even officially
went live
they were asking about now maybe this
means that they're going to add um
oh gosh what was it quidditch or
multiplayer or some some big thing that
or um another year or career or
something
i don't think it's to add anything
i mean two months is not enough time to
add something guys two months is enough
time for us to
make sure what what we've got is in
a top-notch state that's what that is
i mean
if you're gonna add a bunch of stuff
that's like a one-year delay
so way back when we got the initial uh
delay that pushed it to
2020 wait hold on i'm getting my days
mixed up now
when we had the delay that pushed it to
2022
maybe then they decided to add some
stuff in
but not now no they're they're very much
from what i understand i mean from what
they've said publicly from what i've
heard from talking to my source i mean i
think they're very much in the home
stretch
they are
squashing bugs they're wanting
everything to run
as solid as it can run
and i think that's what they're doing i
think this is purely
for a polishing and
i'm only going to mention it i'm only
going to say the name of this game one
time this stream
but i think it's to avoid a cyberpunk
situation
there i'm not gonna bring it up again
um but i i do think that's uh
i think that's mostly what the delay is
david a good night david thanks for
stopping by and hanging out scarlett got
a head out as well scarlett thank you
for hanging out as well
oh somebody said poet made a really
great point let's see
our character is the reason the owls
start
[Music]
yeah we know that owls are supposed to
be
fifth year
don't say that word right
yeah i'm i'm so
when hogwarts legacy got delayed the
first time i made a video about it
because it's like every
so many comments are like talking about
it
and i was just sick of it but after i
mean after talking with this person
behind the scenes and to and just you
know reading the industry
it's clear it's had an effect on the
industry i mean i don't think anybody
can deny that at this point as much as
it pains me to talk about and bring up i
mean the fact that there were a lot when
when there are lawsuits i mean that
because that's when it's one thing if
it's just like a big social media
uproar that quiets down after a while
right
but it's another thing when these
companies start
when the money starts getting affected
and cd project read they ended up settle
settling i was looking into this the
past week they ended up settling that
lawsuit for
i mean to us what would be a huge amount
but a very paltry amount for a company
of their size i think it was like 1.85
million don't quote me on that but it
was it was less than 2 million that they
settled
all of those
lawsuits for which for them is like a
drop in the bucket basically
but
it also
really hurt their stock price
and i i looked into their stock price as
well which has not recovered now
there are a lot other things going on
with economies across the world
that i am
i am not a financial guru i don't even
pretend to understand but
from what i know this the botched launch
of that game
the game that must not be named
there we go that's what i'm going to
start calling it
that's what i'm going to start calling
it poet the game that must not be named
so
the game that must not be named
definitely affected their stock price
no doubt
um so yeah when the money starts getting
hit other game companies are gonna start
to pay attention
and so
i think that was a wake-up call for a
lot of folks
a lot of folks
white wolf says i really think they just
knew they couldn't make it by december
so they had to push it all the way to
february
that is another yes white wolf i'm so
glad you said that
because that is such a great point i
mean initially when they first announced
holiday all the way back in march i mean
holiday that is basically like a four
week four to five week window you know
of
that thanksgiving black friday time
period
to about
two weeks before christmas that's it
you're not gonna release too close to
christmas because you don't get to take
advantage of the whole holiday shopping
season
um
so you're just not gonna do that you
know so that basically blocks off
i would say from about december
let's see let's look at the calendar for
this year i don't know where everything
falls this year
so i would say basically from like
december
17th on
december 16th which is a friday this
year anything from there on was blocked
off they're not gonna do that
and then like you said a few
few games released like january early
january
so then you're looking at late january
early february and then they kind of
settled on early february
which i think will also be a good time
for them to release i know
december uh that this early december
time frame would have been spectacular
for them it would have
i'm not going to deny that december 6th
would have been an incredible launch
date
they would have i mean they would have
had
so much of the attention on them and
been able to take advantage of the
holiday season
no denying that at all but yeah you're
right once once you get past those
couple weeks then
you know
you're not going to release early
january
i mean because here's what here here's
what happens guys and troy pointed this
out in his
big reply and wife once a wizard's post
i mean think about how many companies
and and sounds like the way that video
game companies work is there's a lot of
vacation time
and from what troy was saying it sounds
like a lot of them may have to come in
and work now over those holiday periods
but a lot of companies take like two
weeks at christmas or
you know a week around new year's like
they take that that christmas and new
years just rolls right in for this you
know big two three week period where
there's a lot of people taking off work
so it you're not gonna release a game
during that because of so many things
that would have to go into that
hey sahil thank you for the subscription
to the channel welcome
you're a wizard harry and david as well
david thank you so much
man you guys are showing crazy love and
support tonight the super chats the subs
very much appreciate it guys
very much appreciated uh for anybody
who's just tuning in
i am not sure yet if i'm going to be
able
to co-stream the gamescom thing
um
that's right in the middle of the
workday for me unfortunately but you can
rest assured that that night i will have
a reaction video
going up and then of course an eventual
trailer breakdown
whatever we get i don't even know if
it's trailer uh whatever whatever we see
i will be breaking it down
maddie almost 4 00 a.m oh my goodness
that is crazy maddie thank you for
showing the support
during this uh
crazy early morning hour for you
yeah i'm sticking with that the game
that shall not be named that's what
we're going with
i am gryffindor dread
gryffindor
do i think we can specialize in a type
of magic
no
and yes yes and no like
i feel like the ancient magic
whatever that is that's gonna be our
specialty that that's gonna be what kind
of differentiates us
[Music]
i mean we already know that's what
differentiates us but in terms of like
well our can our can one of
somebody be really good at charms and
somebody else be really good at
transfiguration which isn't even a
totally confirmed class in the game yet
i think the first trailer show
transfiguration but we don't know that
it's confirmed class
that i don't know i don't know that's
part of the other reason i'm so curious
to see
about classes and how they work
yeah i'm sure uh i'm i'm pretty sure i
saw
both expect a go and podcast now i've
said they'll be
co-streaming pretty sure
what house do you think will offer the
best experience oh
i don't think they're gonna differ
drastically
i mean i think it would be cool if they
did though i'll say that
if you
like
i mean because it clearly the companions
are going to be cross house you know
they've already showed that in the
trailer so it's not like you're going to
be locked out of certain companions
based on
which house you're actually
actually i don't know
because like
if you're a gryffindor
i mean will you be able to build up more
of a relationship with nat's side than
if you're not a gryffindor that reminds
me let me
there was an faq question a lot of us
were trying to figure out if this faq
had been updated
because it's been so long i mean
after they announced the date a lot of
people thought it had changed slightly
there is one line that i noticed
recently
that i've probably read many many times
right here
this one here
will players establish friendships in
hogwarts legacy
some students at hogwarts will become
friends
as players grow these relationships
these schoolmates will become companions
who can accompany players on their
journey expand their abilities
and open up as players learn their
stories
dude that
i don't know why i haven't talked about
that more but that that is exciting
right there i mean that almost sounds
like a persona-like system
where if you spend like
that that i could see where be an area
where you can really kind of craft out
if you spend more time with natsai well
she is super talented at this
so you're in turn you're gonna gain this
ability
and i think it would be cool if like you
can't do them all you know
like in one playthrough you can't do all
of them
then you go you have to do a different
playthrough and then maybe you get uh
poppy has a special ability that if you
level all the way up
oh that would be so cool
but then i'm like i wonder what they
mean when they say expand their
abilities
i'm wondering if that there is referring
to the companion or the player
or both
because like we've seen a lot of
different scenes in the trailer where we
have a companion with us like there's
that that scene with a fig where we
could see figs like right beside us
casting spells
in one of the
glitches that they shared we can see
pretty clearly that the centaurs were
likely fighting on our side as well um
then there's that other like little
dueling scene we have of course the the
cutscene with natsai
so yeah does it mean like
is it like leveling up your party
in an rpg you know leveling up your
party members
oh man
there's still so much i want to know
dude so much i want to know
what are my thoughts on horcruxes we do
not speak of horcruxes here how dare you
ask me about a horcrux
no in terms of being in the game
i must say no
i'm gonna say no i think they're i think
they're gonna try and let their game
stand on its own and not rely on too
many of the
magical
mechanisms
that played a huge role in the in the
original series
[Music]
mary says uh what do we think about the
guy that is with us and fig in the
carriage
in the gameplay trailer watch it again
and be curious about why there's only us
in fig
yeah who is that guy
i don't know i i don't know why i never
really put much thought into him he kind
of strikes me as like a
oh i don't think he'd be like maybe he's
like a ministry official
who is like
in
helping fig you know maybe he had to be
there to verify
when fig picks us up because whatever
the event is somebody else was asking
about that like why does our character
start as a fifth year they have not said
one yet so maybe whatever that event is
maybe he's like a ministry official i i
as i was kind of thinking out loud it's
just an idea that came to me i don't
know
if they show us diving underwater
yeah or if they show us jumping
we could be pretty sure there's going to
be climbing because of that autodesk
cutscene
but jumping i don't think we can lock it
in just yet
hey
assassin what's up welcome welcome
new game plus oh i hope so machop i hope
so
i think that's pretty likely yeah
for an accent rpg
mr xbox fan yo thank you for the
subscription
welcome to the live stream
oh click the wrong button let's see
not being able to befriend every
companion really adds a lot to the
replayability of the game and thought of
that yeah and i i hadn't put much
thought into it either until i was
revisiting this
and i mean the way that sounds as
players grow now let's be fair the way
some gays
some some games do this the way some
games do this is that they give you
enough time to where you can level up
everything which is fine you know some
games take that approach
to where you could so you could get
every character you can maximize your
relationship with them
get all their abilities
so they they could very well do that it
could be a game where they give you
that much time to where you can do
all of that
that's a possibility but i do think it's
also possibility that you're that you're
limited and that you have to choose like
you know this day
there's three characters that
this is how persona if any of you have
played persona you'll know persona
handles like okay you've got
this time period today
which character do you want to spend it
with
and then if you spin it with them
it you know slowly builds up that
relationship
i think i do think there will be dlc i
saw another question about that if if
the game does well
an owl a cat or toad is our pet
i do
i do
i think we'll get to have a pet
previously i would have said no but
after the state of play and that they
showed us that whole menagerie of
magical beasts
which blew my mind like really they're
going they're they're going here
that's amazing
i have not played the hot uh hogwarts
minecraft map but i have heard a lot
about it
i have heard a lot of good things about
it yeah
definitely at least one more snuggle
sharky definitely at least one more
because
we haven't seen a ravenclaw companion
and i just think that would be so weird
if ravenclaw got left out i can't see
them
i mean i i hope there's actually more
companions
i think it'd be awesome if there's more
than four but i think minimum i think we
get four one for each house
headmaster hates children uh yeah if
it's phineas black
which it seems pretty likely that the
headmaster is phineas black for the game
yeah he's not a fan of students
somebody was asking about uh let's see
choices
the choice thing
that's another thing that we haven't
seen at all is like the dialogue
we haven't seen the dialogue at all yo
joseph with the super chat
the 20 dollar super chat coming in
joseph thank you so much for your
support of the stream dude very much
appreciated
very much appreciated
joseph asked do you think they could
stealth drop multiplayer after launch
like with return and ghost of tsushima
uh how do you think multiplayer would
work i would love to see pvp and
forbidden force like the dark zone in
the division
dude joseph so
for the longest time i was thinking on
the exact same lines as you were i said
i was even predicting i was like i think
they're gonna do because so many people
want multiplayer so many people and i
know a lot of people don't before you
guys start let me know i know a lot of
you don't want it to so many people
wanted multiplayer
and
i was predicting for a while that they
were gonna do exactly what you said i
was like i can see a
post-launch dlc two three months maybe
three months after launch of where they
drop it because if you remember a few i
guess it's been a few years ago now
there was that article about how wb was
really doubling down on live service
games and they wanted there to be sort
of an ongoing component to their games
and then then they hired chandler wood
and i'm like community manager
typically you think of community
managers being involved with multiplayer
type games right
but
i say all that
i say all that joseph but now i am
almost
i would say i'm 99 sure they are not
planning it unfortunately unless they're
just pulling a fast one on all of us
two reasons one reason is an faq
question
that they added right here
um and they added this a while ago
hey dread with the super chat as well
dread thank you so much we'll get to
your question here in just a moment
let me uh let me do a
control f yeah here you go
right here they there's this faq
question does hogwarts look as you have
online or co-op gameplay and then they
just outright say hogwarts legacy is a
single player experience and does not
have online or co-op gameplay
i think i mean this is my guess on it
joseph is when they hired chandler i
think he
i think he's doing a good job as
community manager and i think he
probably
was hearing some of uh the creators say
stuff like dude i bet there's going to
be a drop after the launch of some sort
of multiplayer thing
and then like in that very next in the
first thing that he did
oh there was also a line in a blog post
where they said where chandler said we
very much want to reiterate that
hogwarts legacy is a single-player game
and then they kind of tweaked this um
i think they tweaked this response a bit
i don't always remember it being quite
this direct
so if they were to add one then it would
be like a complete
complete 180 maybe they just don't want
anybody to know about it but i so i'm
saying 99
no
um but in terms of like sql or
maybe if the game does really well and
it's something that people kept asking
for maybe so i think the more likely
given this statement and given what else
they've said i think the much more
likely path would be there's some sort
of post-launch dlc for the story
uh and i could i could see it being
related to whatever happens in the
summer
so i mean
i was talking about this on when i was
on with podcast now i mean this game
sets up so well for sequels like you can
have your one school year at hogwarts
where all this big story stuff happens
this ancient magic this goblin rebellion
all that stuff then it leads right in to
summer summer can be your dlc
then it leads right in to your sequel
which would be your your sixth year at
hogwarts so
that's what i'm thinking all right so
dread also had a super chat coming in
there no question dread dread just
showing support to the stream dread
thank you so much really do appreciate
all the support guys um but dred did
have a comment with his a multiplayer
wizards chess would be insane honestly
and right like that one
and i feel like that would be an easy
one to do i i i'm not a game developer
guys i don't want to insult the game
developers on this but i feel like if
you're going to do something multiplayer
starting with the basis of chess which
is a game that we already have all the
rules for
that would be easily doable i feel like
it's just i mean for wizards chess right
it's just putting animations in there
to where it's uh you know some sort of
battling component at the same time
after after you make your move
stick to hurting people's feelings in
harry potter
magic awaken duels oh man i'm ready for
that to release i the re i haven't done
any
anything with magic awaken i made a
couple videos about it but i haven't
played it at all because
all the beta stuff it doesn't carry over
so i just i want to go in and experience
it fresh i've watched james of expecto
go playing it a little bit
um i'm i'm curious to try that game out
for sure
i think that would be a fun one to
stream
oh man you guys just always asking such
good questions and crazy support tonight
with the super chats
with the new subs
what are we at in subs right now by the
way let me check something here
let me go to
my
youtube studio page
yeah we're over we're over 26 thousand
subs now guys which is awesome
26
449
let's go dude
yeah thank you guys so much for that
i've i'm reserving a spot on my wall
over here
i'm i'm going to get you see this spot
right um
right there
i am going to get that 100k
youtube play button guys
with your help we will get there we will
get there
who knows i mean hogwarts legacy
launches that may be just the thing to
propel us there but yeah that's like
goals right there goals
multiplayer dueling club i mean there's
so many things in harry potter that are
set up for dueling club stuff right
yo cat dad tv what is up dude not used
to seeing your name here over on the
youtube live stream
cat dad guys a buddy of mine uh
from over on twitch
cat dad and i we know each other in real
life too so
real life i always
i need to stop saying that this is real
life cad dad and i have met in person
that's a better way of me phrasing that
right
can we get more likes alone it says hope
i'm pronouncing that correctly let's see
what what are the likes at right now
157 likes let's go dude let's go
yeah you guys you got to help me come up
with something like um
a lot of you are fans of expecto goes
live stream too and he does a pureet
whenever he gets what is does he do one
when he gets to 100 and then another
when he gets to 150 and if sue's there
she has to do one
as well
i think that's how it goes i got i can't
i can't steal that though
we got to come up with our own thing
gotta come up with their own thing
logan always so professional streams are
so fun and positive engaging thank you
logan thank you so much man warms my
heart to hear that yeah i i try to
i love how you described it because
that's like exactly what i'm i'm going
for you know i want there's there's a
sense of professionalism but also like
a sense of having fun too
it's a it's a tough balance it's a lot
harder than you would think to strike
that balance
it's like some you feel like they go too
far one way or another but i try to i
try to ride that line so
very much appreciate that yeah
and i eventually want to bring back
gaming live streams too so
we got quite a few people in here right
now i'm betting that not all of you know
my
my kind of history of uh
creating content so just a real just a
real quick overview for you guys and
then we'll get back to talking hogwarts
legacy but i streamed on twitch for like
three years
three nights a week
and like made zero headway man it's just
it's a really tough platform to get
discovered on
and then pandemic happened i had all
this extra time on my hands and was like
dude you know what i'm gonna start
i'm gonna make youtube videos because if
i make good youtube content
people will find it it's just it's much
more discoverable
and so i did and then at that time i was
doing youtube and i was doing twitch and
it was going it was going pretty well
but then i had i went back to work so
the pandemic i was at home for like i
don't know five six months so i had all
this extra time on my hands so i was
like dude i'm all in on twitch i'm all
in on youtube
um
but then when i went back to my regular
nine to five during the day i had to
make a decision on because i couldn't
keep doing both i was like i was putting
out two youtube videos a week and i was
doing
like two like twitch live streams a week
it was just too much
and so the youtube was doing really well
so i was like i gotta make a choice so i
i stopped doing the twitch live stream
so this this weekly live stream that
we're doing here on youtube is really my
first
diving back into that
and so right now i'm i'm i'm not gonna
bite off more than i can chew so it's
like
this is our third
our third regular one yeah we've done
three weeks in a row tuesday night that
seems to be a night it's working well
for my family and i
um but i eventually i want to start
doing game streams again too i'm
replaying through the as you guy if you
guys follow the channel you know i've
been uh
doing the harry potter games and so i'm
on prisoner of azkaban right now but i i
really do i want to bring back the live
streams as well it's just like so like
tonight
i'll try
i will not be able to make any youtube
content tonight at all so then if i
added another night where i was doing
like a big live stream that's another
night where i don't get to
make videos for you guys so it's
it's a big challenge when you've got a
regular job too
plus family and all that stuff
learn how to say it right oh what uh
pure red
i hope that's close enough it's yeah i
don't know it's always been a tough word
for me to say i listened to james enough
though 100 likes equals spinning
spinning in your chair while saying we i
like
that's a funny one i like that
i like that fuzz ball found your channel
two days ago and love that hey thank you
so much
oh you stream on twitch mary i didn't
realize that and mary you have a youtube
channel too i believe right
yeah twitch is just like it's a
different beast and
you know now like with the with the
following i have here on youtube i could
probably go over on on twitch and have i
don't know way more than i used to have
i mean i was like streaming to five
viewers for most of those three years
yeah i would i would think i could go
over now and get hopefully more than
five viewers but now it's kind of like
man youtube has been so good to me you
guys hang out you guys show up big time
anytime we do a live stream here so
i don't know i think i'll test the
waters as we go forward about the the
live show like this this retro-racket
tour live that we've been doing i think
that the home for that is youtube i feel
like for sure but if we if we start
adding games again i don't know we might
try out both and see what happens
house with the 1.99 super chat as well
thank you so much for the support do we
get to use different wands or just
upgrade hours
that is a very good question which we
don't
know the answer to yet
we don't know the answer to
um
there's a lot when it comes to the wands
a lot of people are basing their
reaction to the wands
on what we know about
the lore in the wizarding world so
once the wand oh wait wait wait hold on
i'm cutting out the music for a second
and i want to show you guys a tweet
yo did i see wizardphd in here wizardphd
what is up another fellow hogwarts
legacy content creator
professor lynette thank you so much for
hanging out good to see you wizardphd
i just recently found your videos i'd
seen you in uh james's chat before
but yeah wizardphd makes a lot of good
hogwarts legacy stuff hey there she is
right there
i retweeted this uh this was a good this
was a good one i like this video good
job on that one
where is my post about this
because this just like cracked me up so
much
oh where is it dude
i'm tweeting too much lately
oh i don't think it was this far back it
definitely wasn't
if i don't find it here in this scroll
i'll just sum it up for you guys
but it's trust me it's
it's a lot funnier if i read it
dude i just i had to scroll right by it
oh here it is
here it is okay this is a comment so if
you guys watched my
me i'm gonna pause the music for just a
minute we'll bring it back
if you guys watch my video about
uh
let's see which video was it
see i can't i've got too many videos
guys i can't even um
remember my
it was this one here about the autodesk
session i had a whole segment in here
where i put this disclaimer
about how we uh
how we don't know we can't take
everything for sure even though it's
like kind of official
and when i did it i
here it is right here
presentation this was a
behind-the-scenes look at their
development process point being well so
i did this olivander voice when i
i'm always kind of experimenting new
stuff on youtube you know so i was like
i'm gonna put this in there just to be
kind of funny
i feel like the majority of people liked
it and got
got what i was going for i can go in and
look at my youtube retention graphs and
uh i was gonna see like do i did i have
a big drop here when i did this
i did not which i was i was happy with
but
i did get this comment on the video
which i i take out their name because i
don't want you going after this person
but
this is what they said please don't read
text in a different voice you clearly
haven't practiced them nor are you good
at them
they got me deep that cut me d dude it
comes off incredibly bad example around
328 i skipped through it
oh man
i just i got such a good laugh with that
because i was like
i appreciate your honesty you know i do
i appreciate the honesty and then uh
mark here says this makes me want to
watch the video even more i said you
want to know the saddest part i actually
do practice this particular impression
and so
the person who asked this question here
moments ago
you that question is what made me launch
into this story here
so
what i was about to do for you guys is i
was about to do my ollivander voice
because when it comes to the wands you
guys the wand chooses the wizard mr
potter it's not always clear why so
maybe we practice maybe that's what i do
at a hundred likes
i practice
my ollivander voice we come up with a
phrase that i'm gonna say
i'm gonna work on that this week that's
it i i think maybe
as i spin around in the chair
i say something in the ollivander voice
uh it's all see it's all coming to me
now
so
the one chooses the wizard
and that's what we always keep coming
back to to to get back to the lore here
to get back to the question now sorry
for the tangent but to get back to all
of that um
i've been very curious to see how
they'll handle the wands because the way
it works in the books and in the lore is
that
the one chooses you
and any sort of like customization you
don't really get to customize a wand now
certain ones actually are are better at
certain types of spells
you see this if you read through the
wizarding world
if you go on there and you do the test
and you get your wand there you know you
can read about the flexibility you can
read about the cores
so i can see us getting
those things in the game but it's like
in terms of customization
i feel like it's only going to be a
purely visual thing like maybe we get to
do the lucius malfoy style wand or
maybe we get to make carvings or we get
to tie something on your wall i don't
know how they may do it
in terms of using different uh let's see
different ones are just upgrade hours if
i had to pick one of those i would say
it'll be more upgrading hours
i don't think going to be different ones
because that if you start to use
different ones
unless it's the elder wand
unless it's the elder wand which will
show loyalty if you win the want if you
win the elder wand and it sees you as
the true master then it will work very
well for you
but what we know from reading especially
deathly hallows deathly hallows goes a
lot into the wan lore
the wands do not work well if
it does not recognize the master
and so harry
lost his true wand or it was it was
broken
um so he had to use a temporary one that
i think they took off one of the
snatchers if i remember correctly
and you know it worked to an extent but
it was not like his wand and he talked
about you know how in throughout the
book like
that was dude that was such an epic
moment in that book but like and
like epic on the side of
uh maybe epics the wrong word but just
like this oh crap moment of like dude
the biggest battle of his life and he's
lost like he has lost
his tool his wiz the tool that connects
him
to magic in the wizarding world before
his battle with voldemort he doesn't
even have his own wand
what
that's one thing that i loved about how
that the book ended it's like
but because he was the master of the
elder wand
it didn't matter because the elder one
recognized him oh so good anyway
so that was a really long answer to to
your question that i mean that was that
was a very long answer but hopefully we
covered it there so i think uh if we
used a bunch of different ones i think
it would kind of go against the lore
unless they just like
if you picked up a wan and just didn't
work as well for you so yeah i think
we'll be able to make some sort of
upgrades
i think they'll tie it more into the the
spell side of things
in terms of um like upgrading the spells
rather than the one and then maybe we
get some one customization options
machop entire month streaming to finally
get affiliate that was years ago
love streams where we talk about really
big games coming out like hogwarts
legacy indeed
maybe the wand is in that mysterious tab
chandler mentioned
it could be yeah i feel like that i feel
like that tab if it's not just the house
selection tab
then it's going to be maybe it's
everything that we would need
for hogwarts like
if we're chew if we get to choose a pet
if we get to set up if we get to
get our wand
um
if we choose our house right there
maybe it's like something to do with the
house robes like you get to choose what
your first set of robes look like that
could be in there too
oh man i'm behind on comments sorry i
went off on a big long story there
the voice over didn't sound bad thought
it was pretty good internet is brutal
practice that a particular impression
honestly i mean i that
personally i feel like i can do a pretty
good ollivander
that's kind of one of my go-to's when
i'm giving impressions for people
honestly
so yeah i mean you know it kind of hurt
a little bit it did
it did
but it was the only comment like that
most people thought it was hilarious so
and that like that was part of the humor
too it was like it was it was meant to
be funny it wasn't meant to be me
auditioning for the role of ollivander
you know
it was not meant to be that
yeah joseph that's a good
joseph i'm going back here a little bit
but that's exactly why i thought it
would work so well is because those
multiplayer components were just like
completely separate so if you
all the people that are like i'm single
player only they could still enjoy the
base game all the story stuff all that
stuff is still there so yeah that's why
for the longest time i thought it had a
good chance of happening until they uh
till avalanche kind of came out and said
pretty much no
chair spins are key accio subscribers
that's all alone says that's almost spot
on thank you appreciated
are we starting this tonight you owe us
an olivander quote and chair spin see
the thing about olive inner quotes see
there's not a lot of quotes
[Music]
so i think we would have to maybe we'd
have to do the same quote
my go-to is always the i wondered when
i'd be seeing you mr potter
machop gotta head out hey machop thanks
for hanging out and thanks for becoming
a a member tonight
rocking that retro racket to our badge
let's go
i think they'll add one customization
microtransaction they've confirmed no
microtransactions for hogwarts legacy
that is another thing
that everybody oh it was right right
where i had it left off here in-game
purchases or micro transactions hogwarts
legacy does not have so i mean if they
if they added these after the fact even
if it was like if they added it in a dlc
or something then
they'd have a lot to answer to so i mean
they're pretty much coming out ahead of
this and saying
no not going to be in so
jda thanks for hanging out jd have a
good night
frustrated player how old are you just
curious because you don't seem that old
well i have two young children
frustrated player i'll tell you that
if i didn't have my hat on you probably
think i look a lot older because a lot
of my hair is it's gone it's gone
not totally bald yet but my son reminds
me all the time my eight-year-old
it's like you have no hair i'm like i
no son
there is some hair
but um
speaking of like brutal youtube comments
in one of my videos i was kind of
talking about my history with harry
potter
here's how i'll tell you how old i am i
read
sorcerer stone in the seventh grade
sorcerer's stone and it had been out it
hadn't been out that long but i read it
in seventh grade long before this it was
made into movies i take great pride in
this guys long before it was made into a
movie long before it was you know the
phenomenon that it is now
and
yeah scholastic book order they still
have those things by the way but i was
like looking through it
spotted the covers like hey that looks
kind of cool read the description
i gotta get that book
got the book
and was instantly hooked you know here
we are now all these years later
shadowing thank you for the sub welcome
welcome
so yeah i've got an eight-year-old and a
four-year-old
and then yeah we kind of got like
the beard the beard here it's it's it's
quickly rapidly graying
so i don't know man i can't pull off the
the jude law
jude law young dumbledore look
it also it's like annoying because it's
like it's just like right here
it almost might be better if it was like
you know just like a salt and pepper
throughout
being a member is great niko says
remember recommend sports hey thank you
nico appreciate it yeah if you remember
you get uh you get access to those
slick new emotes which we unlocked
i think i unlocked two more
so let me know in the chat if you guys
have a suggestion because we got the
four houses
so i'm like what do we do now maybe we
do a hogwarts crest
that might be a cool one to have
hogwarts crest could be fun
but yeah i think we got i think we
opened up two more slots
and then i don't even know what it's
tied to on youtube so you might know
like what
when you unlock more slots
i don't know if it has anything to do
with um
it might be members or might be tied to
subs i'm not sure
yeah microtransact no microtransactions
that is a big w yeah
which i'm i'm really curious to see how
hey cat dad cat dab becoming a member
cat dad thank you so much dude
becoming a member here getting access to
those emotes
you like that sound effect there guys
welcome to gryffindor okay i admit i
gotta i gotta work on that one if we
wanna do nearly headless snake
gotta work on that one white wolf
exactly where your beard is straight up
to
i mean like right right there dude right
there
i kid you not like my wife laughs every
time i bring this up but
you look at pictures of me like when i'm
holding my first son my newborn son full
head of hair
beard is like a complete
dark brown throughout
and then you like start looking at his
like as he gets older the hair just
starts going less and less and less and
the beard's like gray and gray and gray
i'm like dude if anybody wants to see
the aging that it being a parent puts on
you
she's like no it doesn't i'm like no it
does it's the stress of being a parent
that's what it is that's what brought it
on
oh let's see what did jay rossi say
mary said some people go bald faster
there's nothing yeah i mean some people
some of my good friends started going
bald like shortly after high school and
then a couple of friends in college too
so it's it's so crazy how uh
how that is for guys you know
yeah i've just
i've just embraced it now and i just i
buzz i don't buzz it like uh i don't
completely shave it down but i just i
just buzzed at this point pandemic
really helped spur that on when all the
barbers were closed
just like
take take matters into my own hands
jonathan different houses mean different
background stories
uh you talk about like for our character
i think the background story is going to
be relatively locked
of our character
hey hi i remember you from last week hi
welcome back
i think the map from the second movie
where you can see where everyone is
oh the marauders map no unfortunately as
as awesome as that tool is
the marauders map was created by messa's
moony wormtail padfoot and prongs
much later in the unless you talk about
a different map
second movie let's see
no he doesn't get it in the second movie
though right
how does he get the marauders map i'm
going totally blank
embrace the ball right yeah
yeah i've fully embraced it at this
point
marwin have to leave because of school
hey marwyn thanks for stopping by we're
we're uh we've been going for about two
hours at 15. i'm see i'm telling you
guys every time like some some nights
i've thought about maybe we should do
like an hour of talk show and then
game play for another hour hour and a
half but everything just always flows so
quickly
gets it in the third yeah i was thinking
it was prisoner of azkaban yeah cause
that's when he learns the whole story of
the marauders so i'm not maybe they uh
let's see who is that that asked
it was high one two three
yeah it probably meant third movie
mary he's the reason i start i mean that
that's how i feel that's how i feel
indeed
started poet started going bald right
after high school two
you do have a glorious beard nice yeah
man like when you
that is such a
there's like so many uh
youtube videos of like
the guys who just embrace the bald and
then they go with the beard look too
it looks so good
like 99 of the time it's like
once it starts to go if you just
buzz it it looks 10 times better
jay park a glad he could finally catch a
stream yeah jay park nice to see you
here thanks for stopping by
jay rossi i remember that one choice uh
we get could be our blood is in pure
half or muggle
yeah we'll see that was kind of a rumor
for a bit yeah i remember that rumor
bouncing around
[Music]
yeah dude if the marauders map had been
invented then
yeah they'd have to figure out a way to
get it to us in the game but
yeah marauder's map comes much later
and we know they invented it it's not
like something they found we know they
invented it
created it somehow which like what what
kind of magic could go into that dude
that might be a fun theory video like
what the heck
like
all the w the great witches and wizards
that came before them it was like they
it's it's pretty clever that's for sure
46 no not that old no no no
about subtract about 10 from that and
you're you're pretty close then
frustrated
dude we got gandalf here now
we've had gandalf here we've had ran
rock we've had jon snow
here in the chat tonight
dragon age inquisition you'll be called
by game issued last name panda headset
panda hat says that's sort of what i'm
thinking too that the last name will be
set but that will get to choose the
first name
very curious about what the characters
in the game calls yeah because if they
have it set
then you know if they have the last name
set then you don't have to worry about
gender you don't have to worry about um
trying to figure out if somebody is a
like if they pick their first name you
don't have to worry about trying to
program that into the game somehow you
just have it set that it's this is the
last name
regardless of the type of character you
create
and regardless of what you make the
first name
steam page updated correct
release date tone says did they add the
uh
can you pre-order yet on steam tone have
they added that yet i might actually
check that right now because people keep
asking me for that
because you can pre-order on um
you can pre-order now on the major
[Music]
i know for sure if you live in the us i
don't know what it's like for the other
countries where if you guys can
pre-order yet
but um like for console editions let me
look here steam
store
hogwarts legacy
because last time i checked it was still
just add to your wish list
yeah still just add to your wish list
but you can see exactly what tone was
saying there they've confirmed that
uh there it is right there plan release
date
february 10
2023
which by the way that is a friday i
talked about this in my video with i
think that all but confirms that
part of the collector's edition whenever
they do announce it
one of them is going to have a 72 hour
early access
yeah i don't i don't think blood status
is going to be in the game either i i
think that it may be but i feel like it
would be set for the character
although imagine if like you're muggle
born
and then uh phineas black he like treats
you differently
if you're
if you're the muggle born
uh let's see evan was saying something
about could have been a
legit leak that got deleted
i'm not sure if you're talking about
that or something different
yeah frustrated player you're you're
right there now you're right there
yeah definitely i would i would
definitely want to see it be being
relevant to the story if they did
uh you could pre-order on oh you might
hi
you might be talking about the digital
version probably right because you could
pre-order the console versions the hard
copies
but let me see here
xbox store they probably still haven't
added i'll check playstation as well
hogwarts legacy xbox
uh they still say available 2022.
so they don't have anything up there yet
uh
let's see
pull chandler's tweet back over here
playstation store
hogwarts
legacy
[Music]
but i know it's on here what how does it
not come up when i
i literally search hogwarts legacy in
the uh
look at this
how crazy is this you guys
playstation store hogwarts legacy
nothing shows up
i mean really
and i know it's on there i've seen it on
there
okay so if i google it i'm able to find
it
but yeah still just uh adding to
wishlist and
release date to be determined which we
already know it has been determined now
so it looks like they're just slow
getting all of it uh
updated
i also want to see if
let's see if amazon is updated
to the correct date now
dude you still can't even get like if
you go on amazon right now and you
search hogwarts legacy same thing is it
won't show up now if you do hogwarts
legacy ps5
then it'll show up
yeah they've updated it
sorry i'm not gonna show my amazon page
because i'm like
paranoid that there's something on there
that's like
i'm gonna like show my credit card to
everybody but
yeah it's on uh amazon has updated oh
they've updated it for
so ps5 ps4
xbox one
xbox series x yeah they've updated for
all those and then the nintendo switch
oh my gosh nintendo switch says december
31st 2023
yikes they're just throwing on the 2023
placeholder now
oh man
yo hogwarts legacy in the chat
ladies and gentlemen the official they
got the check mark there you guys
stopping in to say hi
hogwarts legacy what is up
yeah i had uh i had it minimized so i
was looking through we were checking all
the retailers to see if they had updated
yet with the new dates
hogwarts legacy everybody say hello to
the official hogwarts legacy account on
youtube guys
yeah we were just taking a look at
seeing who all had updated things so it
looks like
xbox hasn't updated yet but steam has
updated
steam has the correct date now here we
go
february 10 2023
but no pre-orders yet on steam
so hogwarts legacy if you're still here
hanging out we did a uh
we did a poll earlier
that asked
i don't think this shows up anywhere now
i did screenshot it though
we've been saying hi i'm late
you guys are like five minutes ago
oh man
i also think there's like that little
bit of a chat delay anyway there's that
little bit of a chat delay
jonathan oh man now i gotta scroll back
this is hilarious
see
you guys are freaking out like retro
retro wake up
wake up
oh that's hilarious
give us a scoop
their lips are sealed until next week
right next week we're getting more
another three minutes at least okay so
at least at least that didn't take that
long
after the stream
dude imagine if enough chats went by
where i completely missed it
blame it on the channel yeah yeah guys
there's a
i've got like a five minute delay
programmed in didn't you know that
chandler is that you evan says
that's good question i wonder who does
run the uh
run their youtube okay yeah so we did a
poll
i screenshotted this so we could uh pull
it back
we did a poll on
let me go into my saved picture so i can
uh
i'll actually pull it up so everybody
can see it if you weren't here in time
to vote in the poll
so hold on that's not what we want to
see i need to crop this here
but i asked what would you most like to
see
next week from hogwarts legacy at
gamescom and i made it difficult because
i mean there's so many things people
want answers to right there's so many
things
all right let's save that
and here are the results so
hogwarts legacy
it's not going to be difficult
i mean look at this
we we did not make it easy for you what
would you most like to see from hogwarts
legacy at gamescom 23
character creator
23
combat breakdown 21 story trailer
33
classes breakdown so classes breakdown
did come out a little bit ahead but i
mean look
look at that almost dead even on those
three
who knows maybe we'll get all four guys
all four in one big package
but so i mean the good news is let's see
how many votes we had 151 votes on that
151 votes
so regardless of what you show hogwarts
legacy i mean i think people are going
to be thrilled they're going to be
pumped and excited
[Music]
it was what we wanted yeah yeah
antoine by the way take as much time as
you as you need make the game as good as
you can at launch patient just want a
good game not a rush game
right
right
i mean this is a game that is well like
they said in the story in the uh
after the state of play i mean chandler
said it
it's a game that's
20 years in the making of people wanting
a game like this
wanting a game like this
so
and i love the fact that
i mean clearly this means that wb is uh
is down for that too you know
because
it's easy for the i mean i could see the
company the sort of the big wigs being
like no
get the game out
just release the game fix it later but
the fact that wb is being patient enough
and saying yeah take take more time i
think is a good sign a good sign
incredible stats on that poll right ryan
right
yeah hogwarts legacy they're like we
can't say much but it is it is
interesting indeed
what do you think we'll see in this
week's thursday twitter oh that's a good
that's a good question will we get a
thursday post
will we get a thursday post because
i mean that's a pretty big drop that
came today
on a what is today tuesday that came on
a tuesday that we're gonna get some
something you know relatively big it
seems like at gamescom
ryan last name i think we'll see all of
the above oh that'd be incredible right
take my money for the collector's
edition already
it'd be cool if at the end of the game
we made it first your dumbledore
that the only way that could happen
pandas if we go
three years which my my expectation is
that the game will just be one year
we'll see though i mean we'll see that's
that's not confirmed um i i kind of feel
like just from the history of harry
potter
it just feels like a one-year a one-year
i mean it's a it's a good span of time
for a game at a school to take place
it's like you have one school year
because if they if they go more than one
year which would
blow my mind if they did but if they go
more than one year well then i mean all
of a sudden that opens up things
a lot more than we were imagining
because then if you go to year seven
you're exactly right you got to meet you
got to meet dumbledore
you'd have to be dumbledore
27 years i feel like a child waiting for
christmas
well it's funny there are so many people
who keep telling me like
i i i've read so many comments on reddit
and in youtube comments
on my channel and other people's channel
of people who don't even play games
regularly i feel like most of you the
most of the regulars in this chat most
of the regular names i see probably do
but there are so many people who
are are
wanting to get into video games just for
this game or haven't played games in a
while but because they grew up loving
harry potter they're gonna play it
pc gamer trying to figure out how to get
some physical collectors edition just
about ready to buy a ps5 copy for the
steelbook get a digital on pc still
well i mean the
shadow they haven't announced the
official plans for that yet so what we
saw on what was circulating online was
stuff that they
probably weren't ready to get out there
yet um but
the important thing about that is none
of that was final
so yes it was on the avalanche website
hidden in the code but that could have
just been things that they were testing
it may not have even been
definitely what they were going with
there could be more than what we saw
there there could be less
we have no idea so there could very well
be some sort of a
pc collector's edition which
i think would be kind of cool i don't
know if that's a i saw somebody ask this
and expect a ghost chat
and
i'm not a big p i i have a gaming pc now
but like growing up and for i don't know
most of my life i've been a console guy
so i don't know
what's kind of the history with pc games
and collectors editions
is really
i mean do they is that like a thing do
do pc games do that a lot because i
can't
i can't really recall one but
again like i said i'm not really a big
pc gamer so
type without looking at the keyboard oh
yeah frustrated player yeah yeah
yeah i had a keyboard in class back in
high school
and then honestly like
i grew up
i mean i grew up using computers all
throughout school so
great skill to have by the way for
anybody who
um
doesn't like i work for a library in in
my old job at the library i used to help
a lot of people with computer classes
and that skill like you can you could
just work so much faster so much more
efficiently when you can uh
when you know when you know how to type
without uh
what do they call it like hunt and peck
typers
which is like you know when you have to
look down and which is fine you know but
especially if you do a lot of typing
it's just super efficient to learn
pc games used to have cd right yeah
they just they had just as big or better
collectors editions but now pcs don't
have disk drives right
got a collector's edition for world of
warcraft now see that one i feel like a
different story cause world of warcraft
is only pc
right
that's only pc
now the interesting thing i don't know
if you guys have seen this the trend in
some games now even console games is
they're releasing
they're releasing the
so like the god of war collectors
edition for example comes with all these
physical items but it does not come with
the physical box of the game
it comes with a steel book or whatever
but it doesn't
it doesn't come with the game itself
comes with the digital code for the game
because
they have ps5s now
that are digital only
so if somebody
bought that version if they have the
digital only ps5
then they would be out of luck whereas
the people that have the disc version
can play both i'm personally not a fan
of it but i get it i understand the why
i mean all the logistics that would be
involved with if they wanted to do a
collector's for disc and a collectors
for digital
would be
monumentally challenging to to pull that
off
i agree with you jonathan yeah i can't
wait to see how the combat is gonna play
out
that's gonna be awesome
to see
let's see i saw wizardphd it's great to
see
oh see i'm trying to keep up with the
comments i'm not sure what that one was
in reference to my apologies
squeak with joy when you saw the
original release then cried when 2023.
dallyboy theorized it'll be more like a
story that won't even span over a whole
year but maybe like half of it so that
it has that whole open world once the
story is over
that's another big question dallyboy is
how
because you gotta think once the game is
over we're gonna be able to still kind
of free roam finish up on trophies
achievements all that
so i think what um
i think and what a lot of others think
is that will the game will just put you
before the last story mission which is
what a lot of open world games do that
have like a big story too is they'll
just put you right before the last story
mission so you're playing through you'll
go you'll beat the game and then it will
say hey we've placed you back before the
last mission where you're free to roam
and gather collectibles all that kind of
thing
and then they'll probably have i would
guess they'll have a new game plus two
yeah
well the more cool stuff coming later
they promise be what appears at gamescom
i think that's definitely part of it nay
i do i think that's part of it uh
chandler's tweet though i mean
i don't think that's gonna be it i don't
think that's gonna be all i feel like i
i love that they're doing the weekly
updates
so we're getting those updates each week
i'm now that somebody mentioned like i
wonder what this thursdays will be i'm
like oh i don't know we'll be will we
get one this thursday because
they got the gamescom thing and then
they just announced the date last week i
mean i guess we would because we haven't
gotten
today was just more an announcement that
that's happening next week
but yeah i think there could be even
more stuff after that if sony has a big
event this year which i think the latest
rumor i don't even try to keep up with
all the sony rumors too but i think the
latest rumor was saying like october
possibly
hey hogwarts legacy oh nice let's go
dropping the news right there
going to head out haven't forgotten
about thursday's yo
awesome to hear hogwarts legacy and
thank you for stopping by and saying
hello to everybody
here in the stream at this late hour
hogwarts legacy
well maybe it's not if you're if you're
west coast there
maybe it's not too late
actually i'm not sure what time uh
the folks at avalanche are on
that's utah right so
yeah 10 43 for me so hopefully it's not
too late for you but definitely after
normal working hours hogwarts legacy so
appreciate
definitely appreciate you stopping by
all right guys you heard it here first
sounds like the thursday post
is still on the way
wizard phd last comment was great to see
people who have it game yes exactly be
hyped about hogwarts legacy
well that's kind of the special thing
really about harry potter in general is
like harry potter really
for people of my age back in my day i
mean for my generation harry potter
got a lot of kids reading for the first
time and understanding how fun and how
engaging reading can be
and so it's always kind of had that that
legacy that history and so now it's like
i don't know tying into video games a
little bit too like oh these people who
grew up loving these books
loving these movies
now there's this other you know this
other whole i mean can you imagine if
somebody who's never played video games
and then they play this and they're like
then they start getting into other games
like
skyrim and elden ring and just all the
other fantasy games it's awesome
last story mission is probably getting
on the train
getting on the train to say goodbye yeah
because it it seems like we're not gonna
arrive at hogwarts on the hogwarts
express so
maybe we could get it on the other side
going home
[Music]
white wolf heading out a white wolf
thank you for stopping by have a good
night
utah is 8 43 gotcha okay so they're
they're two hours behind me then yeah
[Music]
any other series i've been reading
yes actually i just started reading i'd
never read a brandon sanderson before
and i've heard so many good things i
started reading
steelheart
which is really interesting so far i'm
kind of it's taken me a little a little
to get used to the writing style but i
think it could be part of that could be
because it's a
it's told from a perspective of i think
it's an 18 year old kid who's telling
the story
um maybe kind of a weird place to start
with sanderson but
i was checking it out on my uh
library on my kindle an ebook
and um mistborn what was out it was
checked out that was one i was gonna
check on
so i didn't do that one
and then there's another big sanderson
one that um
is like the other his other probably the
biggest one
and so that one was checked out too and
then i was like oh let me i went to his
website and he has like a little
breakdown of like here's some good
starting points and steelheart was
another one that was like a good
starting post like okay i'll start with
that one
mistborn is the one i miss born yeah
mistborn is probably what i'm gonna
read
next although steelheart i think that
one is the reckoners i think it's three
books so i don't know if i'll jump right
into the next one or not
if you're an older if you're someone who
grew up with harry potter
and
you're i don't know
mid mid 20s late 20s early 30s 40s if
you're anywhere in that range i highly
recommend the dresden files if you
haven't read them
the dresden files
are
amazing
they're amazing and it starts off like
the first two the first one i think
it'll be enough to hook you second one's
okay like pretty good then the third
from the third one on it just like takes
off i mean it just takes off
it's a game that a game it's a book that
like starts like you feel like oh this
is the world it's about a wizard who's a
detective
and he's an in each book is going to be
him solving these crimes that involve
magic you know and like the first two
books that's kind of what it is and then
you get to the third book and the world
like the world just starts getting
bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
oh we got some dresden files fans in
here as well nice they are man they're
so good
like if you grew up liking harry potter
i feel like you would enjoy these jim
butcher is the author
and i that was a pandemic read for me i
read through the whole series during the
pandemic
i haven't read through the uh short
stories yet i hear they're pretty good
too
um
but yeah he's got like several more
planned and then there's supposed to be
a trilogy that's going to wrap
everything up
yeah king killer is great too but
where's that book three where's the book
three
way of kings yes antoine thank you
just finished stormlight archive that's
another one yeah that's right dude
sanderson is just it's insane how fast
that man can write
i saw somebody asking about the switch
version
i'd love to know more i'd love to know
more i think it could very well be
something with nintendo's certification
process
from what i've heard it kind of takes a
little bit longer
hopefully it's not going to be much
longer than the others i mean maybe it's
going to be like a march
or like a late february
i mean ideally it'd be like a couple
days a week later
oh man so many good comments
joe what's up joe i didn't see you here
that might be your first comment joe
dresden files was great wish the tv
series went further i didn't watch the
tv show yet i heard it's like very
different from the books but kind of
like its own
you know as long as you consider it sort
of its own thing
but yeah they didn't do them very uh
didn't go very far into them
yes zachary the hopping pot
yes
mistborn and stormlight archives are
gonna get adapted really
yes i just saw the announcement on that
i saw um
i saw brandon's youtube video where he
was talking about that
antoine personally not a fan of most
things sanderson his fans really love
him you might have loving him too wait
which one did you uh did you recommend
mistborn
you said miss born is the one i should
try first yeah i've heard i've heard
from some people saying
and i'm kind of getting a sense from
that with steelheart like but again i
don't know how much of that is because
of the fact that it's written from the
perspective of an 18 year old
but for me the writing style so far i'm
about halfway through it
i don't know how to put it it just seems
like very kind of matter of fact like
this is what happened
and it seems it's just like very
straightforward
so far
and i don't feel like there's a lot of
nuance to it yet
now again i'm about halfway through
but yeah we'll see i'm definitely i
definitely want to try mistborn though
just because i you know that one's kind
of a classic at this point
the emperor's soul is your favorite of
sanderson nice
true jedi love the sith just subscribed
hey thank you so much appreciate that
not sure why it didn't pop up sometimes
i feel like the subs on youtube are
delayed a little bit on twitch it's like
well on twitch the sub is
it's a paid thing whereas youtube subs
are free and membership is what you pay
for
but even um even follows on twitch they
pop up pretty quickly but for some
reason i think on youtube it takes them
a second
ah
oh there maybe they're probably through
now dragon master with the sub thank you
so much
welcome
to the stream
oh interesting so that's kind of your
thing too
yeah we're way off hogwarts hogwarts
legacy the official account stopped by
they headed out
now we're just on a completely different
topic
oh that's kind of a bummer though if
it's like if it sticks like that
because the the prologue of steelheart i
was just like oh my gosh this is
incredible
this the setup the premise is awesome
and i'm like i mean i'm enjoying a story
but it's just very
i don't know i don't know how to maybe
i'm not i'm probably not describing it
well but it's just sort of a dry this is
what's happening
aj rossi heading out appreciate you
stopping by as always
druid or iron druid chronicles if i like
drasnophiles ooh i think i think i've
heard about that one
i think i've heard of that one
oh my gosh we're nearing three hours you
guys we're nearing three hours
oh i gotta hop out guys i gotta go
antoine uh i did yeah i'm gonna do uh
i'm gonna do um
gryffindor yeah that's my house for sure
that's my house house pull of what you
want to be in oh we'll have to do that
one next time maybe that's a good idea i
think i did a poll on that on my um
on my youtube community page
[Music]
evil ravenclaw is most likely my
favorite harry potter film oh man
that's such a tough choice because i
i love the book so much
that i have
problems with each of the films
i was just watching the the super car
super carlin brothers did a
it's like an hour plus long video of
them
ranking all of the harry potter films
and i disagreed with quite a bit
because it's like on one hand i feel
like one and two are the most book
accurate
but i don't really like i love them for
what they are but i don't like love them
love them as films
goblet of fire is like a mess across the
board
but i love the graveyard scene because
like that was the most important scene
and they nailed it
so i guess it would come down to
prisoner of azkaban
order of the phoenix half blood prince
deathly hallows
i mean maybe deathly hallows part no
there's so many
there's so many things that bother me
about
all of the other ones
like major things like i'm still so
annoyed that they didn't have the final
battle take place in the great hall
the whole voldemort and harry flying
through hogwarts
i'm just like come on anyway
yeah i thought i thought their prisoner
of azkaban ranking was low because like
my gut reaction is prisoner like if i
had to choose one tonight my gut
reaction would be prisoner of azkaban
because the other ones i'm not as big
i'm not a huge fan of david yates like i
appreciate what he's done but i feel
like
i feel like there's just something about
when he took over i feel like there was
something that his his films lacked that
i just can't quite put my finger on it
yo zachary morris with another super
chat goodnight chat you're the man retro
zachary thank you so much for the super
chats and thank you for hanging out
very much appreciated
oh yeah i love their theories for sure
all right guys i gotta get ready for bed
uh but this has been an awesome stream
man awesome stream we got basically news
that the
we're gonna get another thursday post
awesome to hear official hogwarts legacy
account stopped by we talked about the
delay we talked about the date we talked
about gamescom next week and i still got
to get some videos ready for this week
guys i still got to get some hogwarts
legacy videos ready for this week
uh the let's plays are still coming as
well i know a lot of people uh enjoy the
let's play so i got to get back to
prisoner of azkaban i think i'm getting
closer to the end of that one we'll see
but um man you guys were crushing it
tonight with the super chats with the
subs
and with all the great comments very
much appreciated if you're new here and
you haven't checked out our videos man
we've got a ton of hogwarts legacy
videos a ton of awkward legacy videos
from way back when the game was first
officially announced at the uh
playstation showcase playstation 5
showcase whatever it was called
david yates lacks style yeah yeah
there's something missing there
voldemort got a special death yes that
was another thing that bugged me so much
oh see this is why i mean these streams
we could go on for so long
we'll do it again next week guys next
tuesday i feel like tuesday is kind of
our day this third week in a row if we
do i mean next tuesday obviously
obviously we gotta talk about gamescom
because i don't think i'm going to be
able to live stream it because it's
right in the middle of my workday
but i'll have a reaction video and then
we'll have a live stream that night
hopefully so
guys thank you so much for your support
hope you all have a wonderful evening
and sorry for i'm not sure what ex the
message retracted i see a couple of them
getting
i don't know if you're posting links or
what sometimes the filter
grabs things that it shouldn't
it shouldn't grab so apologies
apologies if it's catching something
that is in error
alright everybody uh have a fantastic
rest of your week
as always thank you all so much for
watching
and i will talk to you again
very soon
later guys